THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING AND
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND IS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON. AND TELECONFERENCE
BUT DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELEPHONE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS THE PARTISAN TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THAT'S
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL TO
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT NINE ZERO THREE
NINE. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THAT HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING ROOM. OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL AND I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING. THIS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS AND
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I GUESS EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND WHEN YOU'RE PROMPTED
YOU. BEGIN TO SPEAK AND THEN ALL
RIGHTY PERSONAL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL ALSO BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
. PLEASE COMMENT ABOUT COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED- LET'S SET BEGIN THE
HEARING AND- LET'S START WITH
THE MR- THIS CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
HERE L. MELENDEZ. NOTICING THE
PRESENCE OF CHAIR EGGMAN AND-
SENATOR PAN IN THE ABSENCE OF
VICE CHAIR SENATOR MELISSA
MELENDEZ OKAY. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WILL REVIEW APRIL
FINANCED LETTERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION WILL
BE DISCUSSING ALL THE ITEMS
LISTED IN THE DISCUSSION SECTION
OF THE AGENDA- BEFORE THE END
OF. ANY OPENING REMARKS NOPE
LEVINE THANK YOU OKAY JUST FEELS
LIKE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE BACK IN
THE SADDLE AGAIN. WITH BUDGET
HAVING. BEEN A WHIRLWIND OF
POLICY MEETINGS SO LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
. DIRECTOR OF A THOROUGH ARE YOU
HERE WITH US AND READY TO BEGIN
. I AM THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR
AND HONORABLE SENATOR. I THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME- I HAVE.
REVIEWED YOUR QUESTIONS I AM
PREPARED TO ANSWER THOSE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO PROVIDE A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL POINTS OF INFORMATION
FOR. BOTH BRINGING YOU UP TO THE
MOMENT AND- WHY C. R. AND- IN
WITH CONTACTS FOR OUR COUNTY
PLAN REVIEWS- I SEE ARE IS
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE AGENCY AND WORK GROUPS
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THE NEDS OF YOUTH IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. ARE
BEING CONSIDERED AN INITIATIVE
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES AND POLICY
DISCUSSIONS THIS INCLUDES ALL
THE WORK AROUND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WITHIN OUR OWN HEALTH
AGENCY. SUCH AS THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS WORK IN
THE CORRECTIONAL AGENCIES SUCH
AS THE COUNCIL ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
OR BOARD SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
SEX OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD OR
QUEZON WE ARE ALSO CONTINUING TO
MEET WITH STAKEHOLDERS OF ALL
PERSPECTIVES. WE HAVE RECONVENES
THE CHILD WELFARE A Y. C. R.
COMMITTEE. SO FAR WE HAVE HAD
ONE MEETING IT WAS VERY
PRODUCTIVE AND WE ARE PLANNING
ANOTHER MEETING NEXT WEEK. WE
ARE MEETING REGULARLY WITH YOUTH
JUSTICE ADVOCATES AS WELL AS
COUNTY PROBATION. OFFICERS WE
ARE ALSO WITH COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS AND OTHER EXPERTS- I
SEE ARE HAS AN OPEN DOOR POLICY.
WE ARE ABOUT TO BEGIN SITE
VISITS TO THE LOCAL FACILITIES
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
WITH STAFF. USING BECAUSE CITY
AND REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS. A BIT
OF BACKGROUND ON COUNTY REVIEW
PROCESS ALL COUNTIES. SUBMITTED
THEIR PLANS TIMELY O. Y. C. R.
AND THE HHS STAFF REVIEWED.
COUNTY PLANT MULTIPLE TIMES.
PURPOSE AND PLAN ABOUT YOU
PROCESS WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE CARRYING OUT OUR
STATUTORY MANDATE AND ENSURING
THAT ALL THE REQUIRED ELEMENTS
FOR PROVIDED IN ANY PLANS. WE
ALSO IDENTIFIED AREAS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE INCLUDING.
FOR FURTHER BUILDING OUT FUTURE
PLANS WE WERE SEE THIS AN
ITERATIVE. AS YOU RECALL WHEN
THE PLANS WERE DUE O. Y. C. R.
WAS NOT YET- I WASN'T HERE YET
AND ONCE WE LOOKED AT THE-
THAT'S YOU WE WERE ABLE TO
CLARIFY FOR COUNTIES A LITTLE
MORE CLEARLY WHAT OUR
EXPECTATIONS WERE. I AND MY
STAFF NOT DIRECTLY WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM EACH COUNTY
THIS FIFTY SEVEN CHIEFS OF
PROBATION AND ONE DEPUTY CHIEF.
WE AGENDA EYES AT THIRTY MINUTES
YOU MEETING WITH EACH OF THE
COUNTIES. IN THEIR TEENS AND WE
GAINED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AND CONTEXT ABOUT THE COUNTY AND
THEIR PLANS WE ASK CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS AND WE DISCUSSED. OF
REVISIONS AND SUPPLEMENTAL
INFORMATION AND OFFERS A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THEN OUR
COUNCIL LISA HEARTS PROVIDED A
SUMMARY OF THE REQUEST FOR
SUPPLEMENTATION AND ASK FOR THAT
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS. WE ARE I'M
GETTING ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
BACK TO US TIMELY. COMMON
REQUESTS FOR REVISIONS WERE
UPDATES ON FULL TARGET
POPULATION INCLUDING NOT ONLY
YOU'VE CURRENTLY IN DJJ BUT ALL
YOUTH WAS SERIOUS OFFENSES WHO
COULD HAVE BEEN SENT TO DJJ THIS
WAS CRITICAL TO ESTABLISH
BASELINE DATA SO THAT WE COULD
MONITOR WHETHER COUNTIES ARE
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF USERS
WHO ARE BEING SENT TO A LONG
TERM COMMITMENTS. IN THE SECURE
TRAFFIC AND TO PREVENT WHAT WE
CALL NET WIDE NEED ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ON FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY TO CARE FOR YOU FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME WAS ALSO
A- AN AREA FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
INFORMATION AND DEEP DISCUSSION
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON HOW
COUNTIES THAT DO NOT HAVE A
SECURE TRACK. WILL SUPPORT YOU
IN FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND RE
ENTRY WHEN THEY HAVE SENT THEIR
USED TO REGIONAL FACILITIES
THOSE WERE THREE AREAS OF COMMON
SUPPLEMENTAL INFORMATION
REQUESTS. COMMON AREAS WHERE WE
WILL BE OFFERING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED ARE THOSE IN DATA AND
THE MEASUREMENT OF- MILESTONES
AND OUTCOMES FOR THE YOU.
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
PROGRAMMING CONNECTIONS WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY IN
COUNTIES WHERE THERE IS A
SCARCITY OF CBO'S. THE END
THERAPEUTIC FACILITY DESIGN WAS
ALSO A POINT OF DISCUSSION AND
REQUEST. FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. WE INTEND TO WORK
WITH COUNTIES AND ADDRESS THESE-
AREAS OF NEED BY IDENTIFYING
BEST PRACTICES OFFERING
TRAININGS AND OFFERING DIRECT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
COUNTIES WHAT R. O. Y. C. R.
STAFF. WE WILL OFFER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BOTH THAT WE SEE
THERE MAY BE A NEED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND- AND
WHERE WE ARE ARE ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY ASKED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THAT THAT WILL BE
DONE IN A VARIETY OF WAYS. WERE
DEVELOPING THOSE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND IN THE PROCESS OF-
BRINGING ON OTHER- ORGANISING
INTERNAL SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND THEN HIRE
CONSULTANTS WHERE NECESSARY WE
WILL HAVE A COUNTY COORDINATION
UNIT WHICH IS ALMOST FULLY HIRED
WE'RE GOING TO BE A- TEAM OF TEN
VERY SOON. I WILL THEN THAT THEY
WILL BE PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
ARE YOU IN MAY OUR REGIONAL THEY
STAFF WILL BE IN PLACE AND
THEY'LL BE ON THE GROUND AND
ABLE TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
COUNTIES AND LOCAL STATE.
COLDER'S WITH REGARD TO THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE WERE
DEVELOPING THE DATA RESEARCH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EXPERTISE IN
HOUSE AND WE ALSO HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH UCLA CLINICAL
EXPERTS. FOR YOU HEALTH IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND HOW TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY ADOLESCENT
DEVELOPMENT WE- CONTRACTED WITH
DOCTORS ELIZABETH BARNARD. DR
ERICA BATH AND DR LAURA ABRAMS.
WIRE I SEE- IS ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING
CONSULTANTS WITH EXPERTISE IN
CRITICAL AREAS SUCH AS
THERAPEUTIC FACILITIES AND
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. THERE HAVE
BEEN- I SEE- FROM YOUR QUESTION
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT SMALLER
COUNTIES AND ACCOMMODATING OUR
YEARS OUR INITIAL MEETINGS WITH
COUNTIES HAVE ALLOWED US TO
IDENTIFY STRENGTHS AND
CHALLENGES- SMALLER COUNTIES
SMALLER COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE
TEND TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED CARE AND
ENGAGEMENT FOR YOU. AND CAN BE
QUITE SUCCESSFUL IN KEEPING YOU
OUT OF THE SYSTEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE. SOME SMALL COUNTIES
INDICATED IN THEIR PLANTS IN IN
OUR DISCUSSIONS THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE CERTAIN RESOURCES NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE THE EASIER FOR
INSTANCE THEY'LL MAY LACK
TREATMENT STAFF SUCH AS. CHILD
PSYCHOLOGIST WITHIN THEIR
COUNTIES OR FAMILIES WILL HAVE
TO DRAW MULTIPLE HOURS TO ACCESS
RESOURCES THIS ENHANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO OFFER CERTAIN TYPES
OF PROGRAMMING. ADDITIONALLY
SOME COUNTIES HAVE A SEVERE
SCARCITY OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FINALLY SOME
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE JUVENILE
FACILITIES. OR THEY DO NOT HAVE
A FACILITY THAT WILL ACCOMMODATE
THE LONG TERM- STAYS AND SO WE
ARE- APPROACHING THESE- THESE-
ISSUES. BY LOOKING AT SOME
REGIONAL APPROACHES COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE FACILITIES AT
ALL OR FACILITIES THAT CAN
ACCOMMODATE YOU FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME. REPORTED TO US
THAT THEY ARE DEVELOPING OR HAVE
ALREADY DEVELOPED AND TO USE
WITH OTHER COUNTIES TO CARE FOR
THEIR USE AND REGIONAL
FACILITIES. THIS IS BEING DONE
EITHER THROUGH PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES
OR THROUGH A COORDINATION. OF BY
THE COORDINATION OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CHIEF. PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA. THAT THE
LEADERSHIP THAT WAS PROVIDED BY
C. POCK DEVELOPED WHAT'S CALLED
A- CONSORTIUM WHICH IS A
MEMBERSHIP SERVICE TO ALLOW
COUNTIES TO COLLABORATE AND
SHARE RESOURCES THAT THEY MIGHT
LACK. SUCH AS HELPING COUNTIES
FIND PLACEMENT FOR SECURE TRUCK
YOU MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
ALMOST ALL THE COUNTIES HAVE
JOINED EXCEPT FOR A COUPLE. HOW
IS- YC ARE HELPING COUNTIES
BUILD THESE REGIONAL CONNECTIONS
OURSELVES ARE COUNTY
COORDINATION UNIT WHICH WE ARE
CLOSE TO HAVING FULLY STAFFED AS
INDICATED IS BASED IN A REGIONAL
MODEL AND WE WILL B WORKING TO
HELP DEVELOP THE CONNECTIONS
ACROSS COUNTIES. AND WITHIN
REGIONS BASED ON THEIR SPECIFIC
NEEDS NOW THAT EACH COUNTY HAS
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE REAL
LINES YEARS NO MATTER THEIR SIZE
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTIES REGIONALLY TO SHARE
BEST PRACTICES. RESOURCES BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS IDENTIFY FUNDING
NEEDS AND ASSIST IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF STRATEGIES TO
WORK WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BUILDING THEIR
CAPACITY CONNECTING CDOS ACROSS
COUNTY LINES. ENCOURAGE AND
SUPPORT CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY
WHERE APPROPRIATE. WHERE
TREATMENT OR SERVICES ARE NOT
LOCALLY AVAILABLE AND OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT I HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR DISCUSSIONS
UP. EARLIER AND THAT WE HAVE HAD
WITH THE COUNTIES. THE COUNTIES
AS INDICATED- ALL REVISIONS HAVE
BEEN REQUESTED REVISIONS ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING SUBMITTED
BACK TO US AS I INDICATED THERE
IS A THIRTY DAY WINDOW THAT WAS-
REQUESTED. THERE HAS BEEN A
COUPLE OF REQUESTS FOR
EXTENSIONS THAT EVERYTHING
SHOULD BE IN BY THE END OF MAY-
ONCE THE PLANS ARE APPROVED WE
WILL POST THEM ON OUR WEB.
WEBSITE ALONG WITH AN OVERVIEW
AND SUMMARY BY MYSELF AND MY
TEAM. WE ARE STARTING THE SITE
VISITS AS INDICATED IN MAY AS
WELL. THE FIFTH QUESTION IS DO
THE COUNTY PLANS REFLECT NEW
MODELS OF CARE FOR LONGER TERM
PLACEMENTS OR ARE THE COUNTIES
PRIMARILY FOCUSING ON YEARS. OF
FOCUSING ON HOUSING IS IN THE
JUVENILE HALLS THE FACILITIES
THAT EXIST TODAY IN THE COUNTIES
TO HOUSE YOU HAVE BEEN RELYING
PURSUANT TO SB EIGHTY THREE ARE
LARGELY THE JUVENILE HALLS. WE
HAVE AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY YEARS THIRTY EIGHT YEARS
IN THE SECURE TRACK FACILITIES
TODAY WHO ARE LIVING IN THOSE-
SECURE TRACK YOU- FACILITIES
HOWEVER THE COUNTIES ARE HUGELY
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT THESE
KIDS WILL HAVE COMMITMENTS FROM
THE JUDGE OF ANYWHERE. FROM ONE
YEAR TO SEVEN YEARS AS THE
COMMITMENT MATRIX CURRENTLY IS
WRITTEN TODAY AND THAT IS BEING-
LOOKED OUT AGAIN AND AMENDED ON
A TEAM OF FOLKS WHICH I AM PART
OF THROUGH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY DONE
A LOT OF. WORK TO CREATE A HOME
LIKE SETTING IN THESE LOCATIONS
AND TO CREATE AN EXPANSE BASES
THAT ARE THERAPEUTICALLY DESIGNS
LARGER ROOMS FOR RECREATION
SCHOOL AND FAMILY VISITS AND
OUTDOOR SPACES SOME OF THE
COUNTIES ARE ASKING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENHANCE
THE EXISTING FACILITIES. TO BE
TRAUMA INFORMED THERAPEUTIC IN
NATURE A VARIETY OF APPROACHES
ARE REFLECTED IN THE COUNTY
PLANS SOME HIGHLIGHT PARTICULAR
MODIFICATION PROJECTS THAT THEY
CAN CARRY OUT WITH AVAILABLE
FUNDS SUCH AS EXPANDING OUTDOOR
SPACE OR SOFTENING THE FEEL OF
THE FACILITY. OTHERS ARE MORE
AMBITIOUS IN THEIR EXPRESSION OF
TRANSFORMATION OF SPACE AS
INDICATED THERE ARE ALREADY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS IN THE SECURE TRACK
PLACEMENTS IN COUNTIES AND
COUNTIES RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
NEED TO ADAPT QUICKLY TO CARING
FOR THESE YOU. IMMEDIATELY AS OF
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THEN
AFTER THE CLOSURE OF DJJ AND THE
RETURN OF YOUR TO THE COUNTIES
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
OVERALL COUNTIES DEMONSTRATE A
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AVERAGE LENGTH. OF STAY OF THE KIDS FOR THE
SIR AND CRIMES. AND THEY
CONSIDERED THE NEED. AND THAT
THE U. WEALTHIEST IN THIS TRACK
FACILITIES FOR APPROXIMATELY THE
SAME RATES THAT WORK THAT THEY
ANALYZE FOR THEIR PARTICULAR
COUNTIES. AND THEY HAVE PROPOSED
ENHANCEMENTS FOR THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR THE YEARS. THAT
INCLUDES STEP DOWN FROM THE
SECURE FACILITIES TO LESS SECURE
FACILITIES TO COMMUNITY THROUGH
FURLOUGHS TO FAMILY EVENTS
COMMUNITY STEPPED DOWN LOCATIONS
AND OTHER PRIVILEGES. EVERY
OPTION IS BEING EXPLORED AND
MODELS FOR CHANGE ARE DESIRED BY
THE COUNTIES AND- WHY C. R. IS
PREPARED TO IDENTIFY THOSE
MODELS AND PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY. TO ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF HAVING YOU STAY FOR
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE SET SETTINGS.
THERE ARE SOME OF THE COUNTIES
TO HAVE CAMPS AND RANCHES WHICH
THEY ARE VERY COMMITTED. TO
RAINY REIMAGINING AND REMODELING
FOR THIS POPULATION AT AT- IT
BOTH THEY HAVE THOSE PLANS AND
THEY ARE. EXPECTING TO BE ABLE
TO ROLL OUT THOSE PLANS AS TIME
AND FUNDS AND RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE. COUNTIES ALSO THE
KNOWLEDGE THIS UNDERSTANDING OF
THE IS STAYING FOR LONGER TERMS
IN THERE- IT IN THEIR DESIRE FOR
FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS THAT ALLOW
YOU TO LIVE COMFORTABLY AND
CONNECTED TO THEIR FAMILIES.
WHILE THEY PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
TREATMENT WE SAW THINGS LIKE
KITCHENETTES WHERE YOU CAN MAKE
THEIR OWN SNACKS AFTER SCHOOL
FAMILY ROOMS FOR YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO SPEND TIME TOGETHER.
PLAYGROUNDS FOR CHILDREN OF THE
USE AND OR THEIR SIBLINGS
LIBRARIES GARDENS RECREATIONAL
AREAS THAT ARE WELL STOCKED AND
PROVIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO YOU. AS WELL AS
THE HOME LIKE FURNISHINGS
IMPROVE PLANNING VOCATIONAL
CENTRES AND A MYRIAD OF OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS THAT IT KNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY MAY BE RIVER RAISING.
A YEAR A CHILD. FROM AS EARLY AS
AGE FOURTEEN TO PERHAPS AGE
NINETEEN OR TWENTY DEPENDING ON
THAT COMMITMENT BY THE JUDICIAL
OFFICER. THROUGH THE LAST
FORMATIVE YEARS OF THIS CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND THESE
MODIFICATIONS CAN MAKE A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN THE
YEARS EXPERIENCE. CERTAIN
COUNTIES ARE CONSIDERING NEW
PROGRAMMING MODELS OF CARE AND
NEW APPROACHES TO IN CUSTODY AND
INGENUITY PROGRAMMING- I SEE
OURS IN THE PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING AND BRINGING ON
EXPERTS IN REHABILITATIVE
FACILITY MODELS. WITH THEIR
HELP- C. R. O. Y. C. R. WILL BE
IN A GOOD POSITION TO HELP
COUNTIES IDENTIFY. NEW EFFECTIVE
MODELS AND ENHANCE OUR ABILITY%
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IN THIS CRITICAL AREA TO ENSURE
THAT THE SECURITY YOU FACILITIES
PLAY A- THERAPEUTIC ROLE WITHIN
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE. THAT
THESE CAR INVOLVED YOU WILL
EXPERIENCE AND AGAIN I CAN'T
STRESS ENOUGH OUR DESIRE TO HAVE
ARE YOU STATE THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF TIME IN THESE- FACILITIES AND
I BELIEVE. THAT'S ALSO THE
DESIRE OF YOUR CALORIES. THERE
ARE ALSO A LOT QUESTION HERE
ABOUT HOW WILL- WHY ARE ENVIOUS
YOU SEE COLLABORATE TO REVIEW
THE JUVENILE FACILITY GROUNDS
PROPOSED FOR FUNDING IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET.
WE ARE IN CLOSE COLLABORATIVE
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT
BEING A CZ WE HAVE A STANDING
MEETING- AT WHICH IS FREQUENTS-
I BELIEVE IT IT DIDN'T GET SET
AT LEAST BI WEEKLY IF NOT MORE-
AND WE NEED MORE FREQUENTLY WHEN
IT IS NECESSARY. WE HAVE THE
OBLIGATION TO CONCUR ON JUVENILE
GRANTS AND ALSO ON REGULATION
PROVISIONS FOR THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES. WE HAVE MET WITH THE
SEC'S JUVENILE JUSTICE STANDING
COMMITTEE WHICH APPROVES
JUVENILE GROUNDS AND I WILL BE
ATTENDING THEIR NEXT MEETING TO
FURTHER DISCUSS. ARTISTS ARE
PARTICIPATION IN A CONCURRING
AND THE GRANTS I'M ON THE
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE FOR
THE REGULATION REVISION. WE AND
THE VLCC HAVE DISCUSSED AN
APPROACH TO POSSIBLE JUVENILE
FACILITY GRANTS. WITHOUT KNOWING
MORE OF THE DETAILS IN THE FINAL
PROPOSAL IT IS HARD TO BE TOO
SPECIFIC BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
INVOLVED AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE STAGES. AND WE TAKE OUR
OBLIGATION TO CONCUR WHICH WE
BELIEVE MEANS TO ENGAGE AND
AGREE VERY SERIOUSLY. AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A MEETING
OF THE MINDS WITH THE SEC ABOUT
THAT APPROACH. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. YOU THINK
YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANY COMMENT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN A HAN
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT THAT. GOOD
MORNING HISPANIC ANYTHING FROM
THE L. A. O. SENATOR EDMUND NOTE
NO COMMENTS FROM THE L. A. O.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I AM I AM REALLY GLAD TO
SEE THE PROGRESS IS THAT THAT IS
BEING MADE. WITH THIS DIRECTOR
OF THE CERRO I CERTAINLY HEARD
FROM A LOT OF- COUNTIES EARLY ON
THAT THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY OR THE
RESOURCES OR THE- STAFFING- BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE- IT THROUGHOUT THE
FACILITIES- SO TWO QUESTIONS ONE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
REALIGNMENT AND FUNDS IS HAS
THERE BEEN CORRECTION FROM. SOME
OF THE PAST INEQUITIES OF
REALIGNMENTS OR OR WE STILL
FINDING LIKE THE COUNTIES ON ON
INLAND HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
FUNDING THAN THE COUNTIES- IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE IS
THAT IS THAT REMAIN A CONSISTENT
ISSUE AROUND THIS AREA AS WELL.
WHAT WE DID HERE THE HOUSE- AND
WE ARE- BUILT INTO THE
LEGISLATION IS A REVIEW OF THE
FORMULA BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR SO WE'RE TAKING NOTE
OF WHAT WE'RE HEARING BECAUSE I
THINK JUST BY VIRTUE OF.
DEVELOPING A FORMULA THAT THEY
THERE ARE THOSE THAT DON'T. FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES AS AS OTHERS COMING
FROM THE STATE SO WE ARE TAKING
NOTE. AND OUR GOAL IS TO
AMELIORATE THOSE DISCREPANCIES
AT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN OUR
NEXT ITERATION AND HOW THAT
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE ROLLED
OUT. OKAY THAT THAT THAT IS
REASSURING- INC. AND SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE REQUESTING THAT PROPOSED
A HUNDRED MILLION TO YOU YOUR
AGENCY WILL BE DELIVERING THE
GRANTS. YOURSELF SO THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE ANOTHER AREA WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE TO APPLY FOR FUNDING
FOR IT'LL JUST BE FROM YOUR
DEPARTMENT. TO DECIDE WHAT WATCH
GRANTS GET FUNDED WHICH
FACILITIES ARE WORKED ON IS THAT
CORRECT WHICH PLANS ARE
IMPLEMENTED. I BELIEVE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHERE WE WILL BE
PARTNERING WITH- THE SEC AND I
KNOW THAT. KATIE HOWARD IS HERE-
AND THOSE ARE EXACTLY THAT THE
DETAILS THAT WERE GOING TO BE
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO. TO
IRONED OUT SO THAT IT'S AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE. WITH THE
ACCOUNTABILITY NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COUNTIES- ARE HAVE
A SEAMLESS PROCESS IN APPLYING
FOR THE GRANTS. THIS HOW DID YOU
RESPOND TO THAT. YES THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SENATOR EGGMAN-
GOOD TO BE HERE AND THANK YOU
DIRECTOR ZERO THAT WAS A VERY
VERY HELPFUL BRIEFING- YES THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
JUVENILE FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS
IN CONNECTION WITH DJJ
REALIGNMENT IS IN THE BSE SEEN
BUDGET I SHOULD MENTION I'M THE-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE B. S.
D. C. SO JUST TO ADD ON. TO WHAT
DIRECTOR ZERO HAS ALREADY
OUTLINED- WE'RE IN ACTIVE
CONSULTATION WITH OUR PARTNERS
IN THE ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
A Y. C. R. AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ABOUT HOW TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY GET
THAT ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OUT TO THE COUNTIES I THINK
THERE'S A CLEAR RECOGNITION FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE
ARE SOME URGENT. INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATED NEEDS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED PROMPTLY AND AS
DIRECTOR OF THE CERRO- HAS
ALREADY OUTLINED WE ARE IN
REGULAR COLLABORATION AND
COMMUNICATION SO IT IS AN AS YET
A WORK IN PROGRESS WE DON'T HAVE
A FINAL- GRANTED PLAN AT THIS
MOMENT BUT WILL BE VERY HAPPY T
SHARE THOSE. DETAILS AS SOON AS
THEY'RE AVAILABLE. DO YOU KNOW
STATEWIDE THEN HOW MANY HOW MANY
USERS ARE STILL BEING HELD AND
IN SOME KIND OF A HAPHAZARD
UNCERTAIN- AREA IF YOU WILL.
WELL I THINK THAT THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF APPROACHES BEING
TAKEN BY THE COUNTY'S AND AS
DIRECTOR ZERO I SPOKE ABOUT
THERE ARE. A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PLUS YOUTH WHO HAVE ALREADY
MOVED INTO- COUNTY- SUPERVISION
WITH THE CLOSURE OF THE J. J.
AND AS CASES ARE MOVING THROUGH
THE COURT SYSTEM- I PERSONALLY
VISITED FRESNO COUNTY ABOUT SIX
OR EIGHT WEEKS AGO AND SAW THAT
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE THERE TO MAKE
SOME FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS FOR.
ON THE SIX SECURING A TRACK YOU
THROUGH OUR HOUSE FAIR- WE HAVE
RECEIVED FROM EVERY COUNTY THAT
HAS- BEGUN OPERATING A SECURE
YOU'VE TRACKED THE SOLIDITY- A
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT IT IS
THEY'RE DOING AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO YOU SENATOR- I
THINK THE COUNTIES HAVE COME UP
TO SPEED JUST AS QUICKLY AS THEY
CAN- TO MEET THE NEEDS. OF THE
NEW POPULATION AND THAT THERE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT ARE THAT ARE URGENTLY
NEEDED TO BE MADE WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS DIRECTOR
OF THE CERATOPSIANS REST THINGS
LIKE IMPROVED OUTDOOR SPACE AND
RECREATIONAL SPACE PROGRAMMING
TREATMENT. TRAUMA INFORMED AND
SO ON- SO I THINK MY BEST ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION SENATOR IS THAT
COUNTIES HAVE DONE THE BEST THEY
CAN UP TO THIS POINT AND ARE
EAGER TO MAKE SOME ADDITIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS YEAH I WOULD AGREE
WITH THE EAGER I PIPE CERTAINLY
HEARD SOME FROM MIND OF- OF NOT
HAVING THE APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES FOR YOUTH. UP AND
THEN I GUESS MY FINAL QUESTION
ON THIS FOR- TALKED AND TURN
OVER DR PAN AND AGAIN THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH I KNOW THIS IS A
HUGE TASK THAT YOU'RE THAT
YOU'RE TAKING ON AN- IMPORTANT
BUT BUT INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
AND WE HAVE KIDS LIVES. AND
SYSTEMS THAT ARE CHARGED. TRYING
TO- YOU KNOW I'M HAVE A HAVE MY
ARMS OUT TRYING TO CATCH THESE
AS THE AS ARE COMING. I KNOW
WORKFORCE CONTINUES TO BE AN
ISSUE AND I VISITS FOR SOME OF
THE JUVENILE FACILITIES AND SAW.
MANY OF MY FORMER STUDENTS
SOCIAL WORKERS WORKING- IN THE
DJJ ARENA WILL WE BE ABLE DO YOU
THINK. IT HAS THERE BEEN
ATTEMPTED TO HAVE ANY DATA ON
BEING ABLE TO- AND THEY HAVE
SOME OF THOSE WORKERS AND MOVE
INTO THE COUNTIES. WHERE THEIR
FACILITIES WERE LOCATED. SO WE
DON'T LOSE THE EXPERTISE OF
PEOPLE TO AVOID ARE EVEN WORKING
WITH THESE THIS POPULATION. I
WOULD DEFER RISKY FOR DIRECTOR
OF THE SERRANO SHE'S DONE A LOT
MORE CAREFUL REVIEW OF THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY PLANTS OKAY-
WELL WITH REGARD TO HAVING THIS
THE WORKERS WITH EXPERTISE FROM
DJJ MOVED INTO THE COUNTIES I
WOULD. DEFER TO- DOCTOR BOLTS
CALL. THE DOUBLES GOOD MORNING
SOCIAL WORKERS YES IT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THOSE WORKERS IN AND
WE'RE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT THE
SHORTAGE OF SOME MARIJUANA SOME
TO SLIP AWAY. SO- BUT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK YOUR OUR OWN
PROCESSES WE GO THROUGH THE
CLOSURE AND THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
WORKING WITH MANY PARTNERS HOW
H. R. ON WHAT THE PROCESS LOOKS
LIKE IN TERMS OF SHUTTING DOWN
OUR OUR OUR FACILITIES AND BEING
WITHIN THE STATE SYSTEM- THERE'S
LOTS CONVERSATIONS OF HOW THAT
WORKS FOR OUR STAFF THAT BEING
SAID ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSION WITH HIM
WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR
STAFF ARE TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE IN THE
COUNTIES WERE ALSO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH DIRECTOR WAS
STERILE. IT'S BEEN GREAT TED
DEVELOP A PARTNERSHIP WITH HER
AS WELL AS OUR PARTNERSHIP IS
THE POP ON INFORMATION SHARING
BEING ABLE TO MEET WITH
INDIVIDUALS PROVIDE INSIGHTS
THAT FOCUS- HAVE QUESTIONS
AROUND SOME OF THE PROCEDURES
POLICIES THAT DJJ HAS DONE. OKAY
THANK YOU THE DOCUMENT. THANK
YOU AND- REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION THE WORK BEING PUT
IN I GUESS AT THE ONLY QUESTION
I HAD SO- AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
THE CHALLENGES YOU PRESENTED IN
TERMS OF PARTICULARLY ARE
SMALLER COUNTIES IN RURAL
COUNTIES- IS A LACK OF STAFF
ALSO I THINK YOU KNOW DISTANCE
IS AN ISSUE OR GEOGRAPHY-
BECAUSE FOR THE PROGRAM IS TO
TRY TO BRING THESE EVEN OUT
CLOSER TO HOME RIGHT SO THAT
THERE AND- SO THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THAT SUPPORTS BUT- WHEN
YOU'RE DISPERSED GEOGRAPHICALLY.
THAT'S CHALLENGING AS WELL
COMBINED WITH THE SAID LACK OF
STAFF- IT'S ADDRESS- IT AND THEN
CERTAINLY IT CAN STAND YOU DOING
SOME OF THESE REGIONAL CENTERS
AS WELL BUT THAT. A SO ARE. WHAT
KIND OF PROTEGER TAKING THAT TO
TRY TO CRACK THAT NOT GREAT
BECAUSE IN SOME SENSES CREATING
A REGIONAL APPROACH IS NOW MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE- I TRY TO PULL
RESOURCES BUT ALSO. YOU'RE
FIGHTING AGAINST THE GEOGRAPHY
SO HOW DO YOU KEEP THE YOU SO
HI. WHAT'S ON THE THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH THE
PARTICULARLY THE SMALLER RURAL
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF. TRYING TO
KEEP. THE SKIP CLOSER TO THEIR
HOMES RIGHT- TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW YEAH AND YET THE SAME
TIME- THEY'LL BE SURE YOU CAN
PUT THE RESOURCES TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT AND OF
COURSE THEY THEY MIGHT YOU KNOW
THEIR HOMES MIGHT BE DISPERSED
ACROSS A LARGE GEOGRAPHIC AREA
DEPENDING ON THE KIDS AND SO
FORTH. SO- I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW
WHAT KIND OF PURCHASED- YOU'RE
FIGURING OUT ON THAT WITH THE
COUNTIES. WELL I THINK THAT LIKE
YOU SAID THAT'S KIND OF THE
GORDIAN KNOT THAT WE HAVE TO
UNRAVEL AND- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN HAVE LEARNED
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IS
THAT. THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR TREATMENT WITH TELE THREE
MEN TELEHEALTH. OUR LOOKING AT
WHAT KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE SOME
OF THE SMALLER COUNTIES MIGHT
NEED- WE'RE LOOKING AGAIN AT
MAKING SURE THAT THEY COUNTIES-
ARE ARRANGING FOR FREQUENT
FAMILY CONTACT WE HAVE ONE
COUNTY THAT. IS PAYING FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND I BELIEVE
CELL PHONES- AND EVEN MAYBE A
HOUSING VOUCHER FOR STAYING THE
NIGHT IN A HOTEL SO THAT THE
YOUTH CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT COMPONENT AS
WELL AS THAT- THE KIND OF. VIDEO
VISITS THAT WE SAW REALLY
EMERGED THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
I'M WITH WITH REGARD AGAIN TO
THE LACK OF PROFESSIONAL
EXPERTISE. I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO YOU KNOW BE- REALLY REACHING
OUT TO OUR MENTAL HEALTH- AND-
CBO'S AND AT I AM IN TOUCH WITH
THE COUNCIL OF NONPROFITS WE
HAVE A GREAT INTEREST FROM
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THAT WANT
THIS TO BE SUCCESSFUL. SO WE'RE
GONNA JUST BE PUTTING OUR MINDS
TOGETHER AND EVEN IF IT HASN'T
EXISTED YET WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE BUILDING- A SYSTEM
RESPONSE THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF
AND THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
SINCE WE KNOW IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR THE YOUTH TO PASS FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. THAT THEY HAVE THAT
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT EVEN IF THEY
CAN'T BE DIRECTLY IN THE
COMMUNITY LIKE WE'RE HOPING I
THINK WE HAVE THIRTY THREE
FACILITIES I BELIEVE I COUNTED
THAT TWENTY TWO COUNTIES DON'T
HAVE FACILITIES. SO THAT WE ARE
GETTING THAT REGIONAL COUNTY
LAYS ON PERSON HIRED BY MY STAFF
THAT WILL BE ASSIGNED A REGION
OF COUNTIES AND THEIR WHOLE GOAL
WILL TO THE WILL BE TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION SENATOR IT WILL BE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING.
WHATEVER WE CAN HAPPEN HAPPENED
WHETHER IT'S TECH. WHETHER IT'S
NOT A- THE ABILITY FOR CEO FROM
ONE COUNTY TO THE NEXT COUNTY
WHERE IT'S HIRING LIVED
EXPERIENCE YOU. SAID YOU KNOW TO
COACH AND TO. TO BE WITH YOU AS
THEY GO ON FURLOUGHS I DON'T
KNOW I'M YES GUYS REALLY THE
LIMIT HERE WORK WERE BUILDING IT
AND MORE. WORK WERE USING ALL OF
OUR IMAGINATION OR ASKING FOR
INPUT FROM OUR LIVED EXPERIENCE-
FOLKS SO- I DON'T HAVE EXACT
ANSWERS BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WERE ON IT BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A SPECIALIZED.
EXPERT IN A Y. C. R. THAT
SPECIALIZES IN RURAL COUNTIES
AND EVEN SOME CRAP-
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE FIFTY
CARE LIES TO THE RURAL COUNTIES.
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
OUR COUNTIES FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN MAKING SURE THAT THEIR KIDS
ARE SUCCESSFUL. IT REALLY
APPRECIATE AN ANSWER BECAUSE-
SOMETIMES THERE'S A LOT OF LIKE
WELL. WE THIS THE USUALLY WE DO
IT NO WE'RE GONNA TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE BUT THE- ALLOWING US
TO THINK OUT OF BOX THINK ABOUT
TECHNOLOGIES OTHER TYPE OF THING
I MEAN IT'S NOT GONNA BE PURELY
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION EITHER-
BUT- NO TECHNOLOGY COULD HELP
TRY TO CLOSE THE G. GOT
GEOGRAPHIC DISTANCE. THINKING
THE- THINGS. RIGHT- YOU KNOW HOW
DO YOU MOVE THE FAMILIES OVER SO
THEY CAN SEE THAT BUT MAYBE I
REALIZE THE YOU THERE ARE
CERTAIN SITUATION BUT AS TO WHAT
THE MOVE THE YOUTH OVER AND
STILL KEEP THEM AND YOU KNOW
THAT. A SECURITY ADDRESS. I
THINK ANYBODY BUILDING OUT THE
TEAM CELLS ARE CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO BE INNOVATIVE. AND
THAT PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO NOT
JUST. SAY WELL WE'LL TAKE THE
EXISTING MODEL AND MAYBE DO A
FEW TWEAKS THAT TO SAY NOT WELL
ACTUALLY LET'S STEP BACK AND-
AND REALLY LOOK AT THIS. AND IS
THIS A DIFFERENT WAY WE CAN DO
THINGS. KNOWING THAT ARE WHAT
WHAT REALLY WANT TO DO IS. YOU
KNOW RECONNECT THE USE SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE- THAT WE DON'T WE
DON'T THEM RETURNING BACK TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE WANT
AND- WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO. TO
THEN BE ABLE LIVE FULL LIVES AND
CONTRIBUTE AGAIN SO- SO REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING ABOUT HOW IS YOUR
HAVE YOU DISCUSSIONS. WHAT KIND
OF SOLUTIONS COMING WITH WHAT
KIND OF INNOVATIONS ARE COMING
WITH AND HOW WE CAN BE HELPFUL
THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND AGAIN THANK
YOU DIRECTOR OF SORROW IS A
GOOD. INFORMATIVE PRESENTATION
AND WE DO APPRECIATE IT
APPRECIATE. THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING MORE. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO- OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH
IS- CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ISSUE ONE EQUITY
IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED I BELIEVE BY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. A ROLE HAND HOW COULD
SHE NOT TO. KRISHNA CLOSE ENOUGH
HOPEFULLY. AND WELCOME VERY MUCH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR EGGMAN SENATOR
PAN- I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY 2% THE EQUITY
IMPLEMENTATION BUDGET REQUEST.
THIS IS FOR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY STARTING IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. TO COORDINATE AND
INITIATE AN EQUITY STRATEGIC
PLAN. THIS MONTH APRIL IS A VERY
EXCITING TIME FOR EQUITY IN
GOVERNMENT IT INCLUDES TWO WEEKS
AGO WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED NINETY. IT MEANS AN
AGENCIES PUBLICLY SHARING THEIR
EQUITY ACTION PLANS AS PROMISED
BY BITING HARRIS ADMINISTRATIONS
DAY ONE EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
EQUITY. AND IT ALSO INCLUDES
THIS AFTERNOON HERE IN
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL OF WHICH OUR AGENCY IS A
MEMBER WILL BE SHARING THEIR
BIANNUAL UPDATES ON RACIAL
HEALTH EQUITY. AND OUR AGENCY
WILL BE FEATURED REGARDING SOME
OF OUR WORK BUT WE KNOW THIS IS
HAPPENING ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT WITH GOV OPS HIRING A
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER CAL OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES CREATING
AN OFFICE OF EQUITY WITH TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIRTEEN POSITIONS AND MANY
OTHER. AGENCIES FOR US TO BE
PART OF A COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE.
WITHIN OUR AGENCY WE ARE ON
TARGET TO LAUNCH PHASE ONE OF
THE PUBLIC FACING EQUITY
DASHBOARD IN OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR. WE ARE CONTINUING TO MEET
FOR OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS WORK IN
JOINING THE STATE LANGUAGE
ACCESS TASK FORCE THAT RECONVENE
IN THE FALL OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. AND WE ARE
INITIATING TRAINING OF OUR STAFF
AND LEADERS AS PART OF COR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE ON
RACIAL EQUITY AS WELL AS OTHER
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN THE
PIPELINE. AT THE AIM OF THE
STRATEGIC PLAN IS TO CREATE A
UNIFIED FRAMEWORK FOR
CONNECTEDNESS ACROSS WORK THAT
IS CURRENTLY SILO. TO CREATE
CONNECTEDNESS WITH OTHER EQUITY
OFFICES AND INITIATIVES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT SUCH
AS ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY-
YES COPS AND MANY OTHERS. AS
WELL AS TO ENGAGE WITH COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXTERNAL
PARTNERS IN DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
PLAN. YOUR ONE WOULD BE FOR AYE.
EXECUTING A CONTRACT IN STARTING
THE STRATEGIC PLAN AND YOUR TO
WOULD BE. PUBLICLY SHARING AND
CO HUSING AROUND GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND EMBEDDING EQUITY
IN THE POLICIES PROGRAMS AND
PRACTICES. AS WELL AS BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE BARRIERS AND
ATTITUDES TO DOING THIS WORK IN
SETTING UP VERY SPECIFIC GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES. SO IN SUMMARY
THIS IS ABOUT ALIGNMENTS WE HAVE
MANY INITIATIVES ARE HAPPENING
BY WE WANT TO HANG THEM ON ONE
SCAFFOLD AND TREAT SO IT'S
PRETTY JAKE AND UNIFIED AND WE
CAN GET THE GREATEST. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. THIS PROJECT
ANYTHING FROM YOU. NOTHING
FURTHER THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
I THANK YOU FOR THE-
PRESENTATION I UNDERSTAND THIS
LET US JUST COMING OUT OF WHAT
WOULD BE EXPERIENCED AND WE ALL
KEEP US CLEARLY SAW THAT THE
LACK OF- ARE THE DISPARITIES
THAT EXIST ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
THROUGH THE COVERT IN THROUGH-
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OUTREACH- SO-
WE'RE I'M I'M VERY HAPPY YOU'RE
LOOKING WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
THAT WE ARE. LOOKING FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM ABOUT HOW WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS AND I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT
ARE MAYBE TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT OUR TIMELINE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT STUDYING
SOMETHING SO LONG WHILE- WE
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
DISPARITIES IN IN THE SYSTEM-
SO. I JUST JUST A QUESTION I
GUESS NOT REALLY A QUESTION-
THERE DEPEND. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT VARIOUS EFFORTS
AND METRICS THAT YOU'RE USING.
BUT I GUESS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I WOULD HAVE IS THAT- MANY OF
THEM SEEM TO BE MORE PROCESS
ORIENTED RIGHT DID WE HAVE THIS
PROPERTY OF THAT PROCESS- ARE
WE- ARE YOU IDENTIFYING OUTCOME
METRICS NOTES ARE IN THOSE IN
THE END CAN I SAY THAT. IF YOU
KNOW SEVERAL YEARS FROM NOW- ARE
YOU GONNA BE ABLE TO YOU CAN YOU
MIGHT WELL TELL ME LIKE- WHAT WE
DID FIVE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS X.
NUMBER PROGRAMS THAT PROMOTED
EQUITY ETCETERA. BUT CAN YOU
TELL ME THAT DEPARTMENTS
ACTUALLY MORE EQUITABLE. THE
OUTCOMES ARE THAT WE HAVE MORE
EQUITABLE SERVICES THAT THE
OUTCOMES OF THE PEOPLE RECEIVE
THE SERVICES IS ACTUALLY MORE
EQUITABLE THAN IT WAS. THEN IT
IS NOW. IS THE- IS THE- I MET
SELF THE LEADERSHIP. BE UPSET
RIGHT NOW SO. THE THE WORKFORCE
ETCETERA SO- ARE ARE WE
DEVELOPING OUTCOME METRICS- TO
GO ALONG WITH THE- PROCESS
METRICS. AND THAT THAT YOU'RE
DONE FINE. THE SHORT ANSWER IS
YES- WE ARE IN THE FINAL STAGES
OF HIRING AN AGENCY EQUITY
OFFICERS WHO WILL BE LEADING
THIS WORK FULL TIME AND PART OF
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS TO HAVE
THE STRATEGIC PLANNING
CONTRACTING TIME TO ALIGN. THE
MANY INITIATIVES BUT YES WE
ENVISION THAT THIS STRATEGIC
PLAN WILL BE BOTH INTERNAL AS
WELL AS EXTERNAL FACING LOOKING
AT US AS THE LARGEST AGENCY IN
THE LARGEST STATE BUT ALSO
LOOKING EXTERNALLY AT. THE
OUTCOMES AROUND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WITH THE MANY PROGRAMS
IN OUR SEVENTEEN DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
THAT STARTS WITH PROCESS
MEASURES BUT IT ENDS IN OUTCOME
MEASURES AS WELL SO. VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES WILL BE
ENCOURAGE JUST LIKE THE BY NURSE
ADMINISTRATION ASKED ALL
SECRETARIES TO DO ACROSS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PUBLICLY
SHARE THESE EQUITY ACTION PLANS
WITH OUTCOME MEASURES AS WELL
SO- WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IT MAY BE SOMETHING VERY
SPECIFIC AROUND. INFANT AND
MATERNAL MORTALITY THE DISPARITY
REDUCTION- BUT THE GOAL IS TO
ALIGN AROUND COMMON DEFINITIONS
AND WAYS OF MEASURING CREATE
THIS A COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE SO
WE CAN SHARE PROCESS AND OUTCOME
MEASURES BOB AND THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES WE AIM TO INCLUDE.
IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN AS WELL AS
IN PHASE TWO OF THE EQUITY
DASHBOARD OUTCOME METRICS AT
APPRECIATE THAT. SHE SHARED THAT
WITH OUR COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I HAVE A BILL SB
SEVENTEEN THAT- ALSO- TRIES TO
CREATE THAT SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
AND NO WE'RE STILL NOT TALKING
WITH NOW NO WITH THE FOLKS ABOUT
THAT- THAT I THINK IN THE AND-
AND I APPRECIATE. THAT YOU ARE
LOOKING OUTCOME MEASURES DEATHS
IN THE AND WHAT PEOPLE WANT THEY
THEY THEY DON'T PERFORM IT IF
THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO SEE CHANGE
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU
BELIEVE AND APARTMENT BELIEVES
AND SO- YEAH APPRECIATE YOU
COULD SHARE THAT- AS YOU.
FINALLY. THEN APPLY THEM IN YOUR
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEBATE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
THIS. OKAY MOVING ON TO ISSUE A
NUMBER TO THE OFFICE OF
RESILIENCE AND RESPONSE AND I
THINK WE'LL BE JOINED BY CHIEF
RESILIENCE OFFICER. IT'S QUITE A
TITLE ELIZABETH BASNET. HI GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH YOU ALL
TODAY- MY ANSWER WAS A BASS AND
I'M THE CHIEF RESILIENCE OFFICER
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AND I'M- I JUST
WANT TO KIND OF DIVE AND SO AS
YOU ARE ALL AWARE DISASTERS IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T HAVE A SEASON
ANY LONGER THE IDEA OF A FIRE
SEASON AND WE MOVED THROUGH IT.
AND MOVE ON WITH OUR DAY TO DAY
WORK DOESN'T EXIST- WE'RE VERY
MUCH IN A TWENTY FOUR DISASTER
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN DISASTER
CYCLE. AND THIS CAUSES
DEPARTMENTS TO CONSISTENTLY HAVE
TO HAVE PARALLEL OPERATIONS
ACROSS MULTIPLE DISASTERS. SO
WHAT THIS REALLY MEANS IS THAT
THE ONSET OF A DISASTER ITS
IMPACT THE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
. ARE NOW OCCURRING
SIMULTANEOUSLY. AND WE HAVE THAT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WE'RE STILL
ACTIVELY PURSUING WILDFIRE
RECOVERY OPERATIONS FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS. ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE STILL RESPONDING IN
SOME WAY TO COPE ED AS WELL AS
DROUGHT IMPACTS AND PREPARING
FOR ANOTHER MAJOR FIRE SCENES
AND WHILE OF COURSE. WE HAVE
MORE DEFINED GEOGRAPHIC
RESPONSES LIKE OUR BORDER
OPERATIONS. SO CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WAS
REAL ORIGINALLY DESIGNED MANAGE
DATED HARPER RATIONS OF
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS AS YOU ALL
KNOW. IN THAT MISSION ALONE
REQUIRES ALL THE STAFF THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY OVERSEES FULL
AND PART TIME EMPLOYEES. SO
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHEN A DISASTER WORK FOR THE
DURATION WAS SHORT TERM AND. YOU
ARE WITH THE TEMPORARY
REDIRECTION OF STAFF THAT COULD
THEN BE REDIRECTED BACK WITHIN
PROBABLY LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS
OFTENTIMES MAYBE LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS DEPENDING ON THE DURATION
OF A FIRE OR SEASON OR SOMETHING
THAT WAS OF SIGNIFICANT COST. SO
THAT'S NO LONGER THE CASE WHICH
REALLY BRINGS US TO THIS
PROPOSAL AROUND FOR A FULL TIME
AND DEDICATED OFFICE AND TEAM.
WHO ARE MANAGING AND LEADING OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE DISASTER CONTINUE
ON. SO THIS REQUEST IS TWO POINT
SIX MILLION ONGOING FUNDING ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
FOR NINE POSITIONS TO OVERSEE
FIVE CRITICAL PROGRAM AREAS WITH
OUR DEPARTMENTS WHICH AS-
PREPAREDNESS. RESPONSE RECOVERY
MITIGATION RESILIENCE AND THEN
SPECIAL PROJECTS. THAT COME
ALONG AND I THINK UP AS A RESULT
THIS. THIS DEDICATED TEAM ARE
CONTINUES TO ALLOW US TO BREAK
DOWN CYCLES ARE SILOS BETWEEN
OUR DEPARTMENTS. UP PUT THE
PERSON MAKE SURE THE PERSON
STAYS AND PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH THAT WE- VALUE HERE
AGENCY AND WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND GIVES US THE
FORESIGHT TO CONTINUALLY LOOK
AHEAD. AS WE HAVE THIS AN
INDICATION OF DISASTERS AND I'LL
STOP THERE. AND SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT I CAN ANSWER-
DEPARTMENT. NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD THE HELLO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS SONYA PADDOCK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- WE WOULD NOTE THAT KELLY TO
JAZZ HAS INDICATED THAT IT IS
REQUESTING THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR THE CREATION OF
THIS OFFICE RATHER THAN
PERMANENT FUNDING. I'M REALLY IN
ORDER TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND
REEVALUATE THE NEED FOR THE
OFFICE AND WHETHER IT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. AND WE KNOW HOWEVER
THAT THE PROPOSAL LACKS
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THIS RE
EVALUATION WOULD WORK SO FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD AGENCY CONDUCTS.
FORMALISTS THAT'S MEANT. AND
WHAT WOULD THEY CONSIDER IN
DETERMINING WHETHER THAT THE
OFFICE HAS BEEN UNSUCCESSFUL AND
WARRANTS PERMANENT FUNDING. I'M
NOR DOES THE PROPOSAL DESCRIBED
HOW THE AGENCY WOULD INVOLVE THE
LEGISLATURE IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION SO. WE WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL AND THEN FINALLY WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THERE IS NO
ACCOMPANYING. TRAILER BILL FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AND- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE
IMPORTANT FOR IRONING OUT SOME
OF THE DETAILS AND LAYING OUT
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE OFFICE- WE
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR LETTUCE. FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION AS AS SOON AS IT'S
FEASIBLE FOR THEM TO DO SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MS BEST A CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
FOR THE FOR THE FIRST ISSUE.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO I THINK- WHEN
LOOKING AT ASSESSMENT YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE'VE LAID OUT VERY CLEAR
OBJECTIVES FROM THE THINGS THAT
WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
ESTABLISHING OFF THE OFFICE YOU
KNOW WITHIN A HUNDRED AND STUFF
A TWENTY DAYS WORKING WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS TO. REALLY PERFORM
THREAT AND RISK ASSESSMENT FOR
EACH DEPARTMENT BY HOUSE FOR
WITHIN TWO HUNDRED FORTY DAYS AS
THE STOP WISHING THE OFFICE OF
RESPONSE AND RESILIENCE
UNDERSTAND THE CAPACITY TO
RESPOND TO ALL HAZARDS AND- AN
EQUITABLE AND COMPREHENSIVE
MANNER SO I THINK WE'RE LOOKING
AT EACH ONE OF THOSE THINGS AND
GETTING TO. THE THREE YEAR MARK-
ABSOLUTELY PUTTING TOGETHER KIND
OF A COMPREHENSIVE REPORT OF NOT
ONLY DID WE NEED BASIC METRICS
BUT HOW IS IT CHANGING INVOLVED
OUR RESPONSE TO DISASTERS. FOR
WHAT WE LEARNED OBVIOUSLY IN THE
PREVIOUS TWO YEARS IN RESPONSE
TO COVIDIEN EVEN. PRIOR TO THAT
AND WHAT OUR DISASTER RESPONSE
FOR LIKE VERSUS WHAT IT'S LOOK
LIKE ARE IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
WITH THIS OFFICE AND BE ABLE TO
SHOW. THE EVOLUTION CHANGE AND
GROWTH AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
SHARING THAT INFORMATION BACK.
IN AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING MORE NOT NOT AT.
ARE WE LOOKING AT SERVICE
DELIVERY THROUGH A CRISIS ARE WE
LOOKING AT THE INDIVIDUALS
DEPARTMENTS ABILITY TO ADAPT
DURING A CRISIS. WELL I THINK
IT'S PAUL- IS THE SHORT ANSWER
SO I'LL JUST USE DROUGHT FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK OBVIOUSLY TOP OF
EVERYONE'S MIND SO INFORMATION
OBVIOUSLY OUR DEPARTMENTS HAVE
THEIR STATUTORY. IS THAT THEY
HAVE STATUTORY AUTHORITY SO FOR
DROUGHT ALREADY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS NOW HOW ARE WE
TRACKING NEW APPLICANTS FOR
CALFRESH OR CAL WORKS HOW'RE WE-
ARE WATCHING THE CHANGING NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS COVERED BY HEALTH
CARE PLANS. ON IN A COUNTY
THAT'S MAY BE AFFECTED BY D.
FOUR EXCEPTIONAL DROUGHT HOW ARE
WE LOOKING AT WHAT PARTICIPATION
DATA SO WHEN WERE ANALYZING
IMPACT DATA. THAT COMES UP TO
AGENCY WORK COLLATING AT
CREATING A STATEWIDE PICTURE IT
ALLOWS US TO INFORM
COMPREHENSIVE DECISION MAKING
POLICY DECISION MAKING TO EXPAND
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS OR
WHATEVER THAT MAY D. B. CREATE
THAT INTENT SEND IT BACK DOWN
AND THEN OUR DEPARTMENTS ARE ALL
GROWING IN THE SAME DIRECTION ON
A COMPREHENSIVE. MISSION THAT'S
AN INFORMED POLICY SO I THINK
IT'S ON BOTH SIDES. OKAY IN AN-
UNTIL IT IS OUR COORDINATION
BETWEEN WHAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING AND THE DEPARTMENT OF- YES
WHICH HAS SOME OF THESE RULES AT
LEAST. WHEN A CRISIS IS
OCCURRING TWO ONE INTERFACE WITH
THE PUBLIC. ABSOLUTELY I THINK
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH- YES AND EVEN
THROUGHOUT THE COVERT RESPONSE
WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW- YES
MAINTAINS THAT AUTHORITY
OBVIOUSLY TO TRY DIRECTORATE
DISASTER RESPONSE BUT THIS
ALLOWS THEM. TO KIND OF HAVE
THIS SINGULAR POINT OF CONTACT
ON THESE LARGER POLICY
DECISIONS- AND ENSURE THAT IF
THEY'RE PUTTING FOR POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
SUPPORT OUR DEPARTMENTS AND
EXECUTING THOSE THINGS SO- VERY
TIGHTLY COORDINATED WITH- YES
OKAY. THEN I KNOW IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHEN CAN WE EXPECT
THAT. I THINK WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT BACK AND- AND WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THIS- AND THEN IN AN EXPEDITED
MANNER. OKAY THANK YOU CAN. OKAY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHIEF
RESILIENCE OFFICER LIKE THAT
TITLE WHEN I SEE IF I CAN GET
ONE OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO- ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. M. I THINK OUR
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER ADAM.
DONDERO WILL BE PRESENTING THIS. BUDGET GINGEROLS LABOR FINANCE
LETTER. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS DEANNA MARTIN I'LL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ADAM TODAY
WELCOME THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
BUT THE YEAR IN THE CENTER
PAMPER HEARING OR PROPOSAL
TODAY. TWO YEARS AGO THERE WERE
ABOUT SIXTY ACTIVE IT PROJECTS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
ACROSS HER AGENCY SINCE THEN OUR
DEPARTMENTS HAVE HAD SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN THE PRAMAC
PROGRAMMATIC ACCOUNTABILITY
YOUNGER WORKLOAD. AND OF COURSE
CORRESPONDING DEMAND FOR
AUTOMATION. WE NOW HAVE NINETY
I. T. PROJECTS RICHER IN THE
NUMBER IS INCREASING WE HAVE NEW
AND ENHANCED PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO REQUIRE NEW
CAPABILITIES. PROGRAMS VERY VERY
MUCH NEED THE SOLUTIONS TO
ENGAGE AND SERVE OUR PUBLIC INTO
SUPPORTER MISSION OF HELPING
THOSE WHO MOST NEED OUR HELP.
AND WE NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TO BUILD THESE
SOLUTIONS BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE THE BEST USE OF THE LIMITED
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE. SO ARE
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO DO THIS REALLY
AND FREEWAYS. FIRST OF ALL ARE
PROPOSAL CAN REDUCE THE TIME
NEEDED TO GET PROGRAMS THE I. T.
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY NEED- AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE SOLUTIONS
BOTH SUPPORT DEPARTMENTS NEEDS
AND AGENCY NEEDS SPECIFICALLY
OUR STRATEGIC PRIORITIES. WHILE
ALSO REDUCING COSTS AND RISKS.
WE'LL DO THIS BY ESTABLISHING A
CENTER OF EXCELLENCE AND THE
CENTER OF EXCELLENCE WILL
INCLUDE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HELPING YOU WITH SPECIFIC HELP
IN HUMAN SERVICES SPECIFIC TOOLS
TEMPLATES AND PROCESSES DEFINED
DOCUMENTED REPEATABLE PROCESSES
AND CORRESPONDING ARTIFACTS.
THAT WILL FORMALLY A FOUNDATION
FOR HIGHER QUALITY FASTER
PLANNING- THEIR PROCUREMENTS.
BETTER DEVELOPMENT AND ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND I. T. SOLUTIONS
YOU ALSO INCLUDE GUIDELINES FOR
DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
WITH ONE ANOTHER SEAMLESSLY SO
THEY CAN ACT AND THIS ALLOWS US
TO CAPTURE AND SHARE DATA AND
GENERATE DATA. THAT CAN INFORM
OUR POLICY AND PROGRAMS AND
SERVICE DESIGN SO WE CAN USE THE
DATA WE'RE SHARING INFORMATION
ACROSS PROGRAMS CAN GENERATE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE
CAN DO TO INCREASE THE WELLNESS
OUTCOMES. AARDMAN'S HISTORICALLY
BEEN DEPARTMENT CENTRIC THERE'S
DEVELOPMENT AND THE CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
WE'RE BUILDING SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL WORK AND TALK WITH ONE
ANOTHER. IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
HAVE THIS AGENCY LANDS IF WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO AFFECT THE WHOLE
PERSON NEEDS THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA. THE
SAME RESOURCES WILL WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE ACROSS
ALL F OUR DEPARTMENTS TO HELP
AND USE THESE TOOLS WITH THE
GOAL OF BUILDING ONGOING SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND REDUCING
RELIANCE. ON VENDOR SUPPORT FOR
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OF I.
T. SOLUTIONS. THEY ALSO
CONTINUOUSLY UPDATE THESE
ARTIFACTS IN PROCESS IS BASED ON
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING THE LESSONS
LEARNT FOR PROJECTS- ULTIMATELY
TO EVEN FURTHER SO AT THE SPEED
OF OUR DEVELOPMENT ARE ALREADY.
THE SECOND WAY. THAT WE CAN HELP
SPEED QUALITY AND TIME. WILL BE
THAT WE WILL HAVE A RESOURCE IS
A SMALL SET OF HIGHLY TECHNICAL
RESOURCES SCARCE RESOURCES THAT
CAN JUMPSTART AND AUGMENT TEAMS
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENTS
ESPECIALLY ARE SMALLER
DEPARTMENTS YOU REALLY DON'T
HAVE THE SKILLS AND HOUSE AND
WOULD FIND IT VERY HARD TO
ACQUIRE THEM. THESE EXPERTS WILL
INCLUDE FOLKS IN ENTERPRISE AND
DATA ARCHITECTURE WHICH WILL
HELP MAKE SURE SOLUTIONS ARE
INTEGRATED. AS WELL AS CYBER
SECURITY AGAIN VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET ENOUGH OF THESE RESOURCES
FOR APARTMENTS WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES WHICH HAPPENS
SO OFTEN RIGHT NOW IT DELAYS
PROJECTS START. IT RESULT IN
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE FORMALLY OUR
ARCH ARE FULLY INFORMED IN THESE
AREAS. AND ULTIMATELY IT MEANS
THAT WE INCUR MORE RISK AND IT
TAKES MORE TIME TO GET PROGRAMS
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
SORRY BE RUBBER QUEST FOR THE
SERIES IS REALLY ABOUT
ESTABLISHING THE CENTRE OF
EXCELLENCE ONE MEASURING ITS
VALUE AND THE BENEFIT THAT WE
CAN DELIVER FOR AUGMENTING THE
TEAM SO WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AND
SAY. ARE DEPARTMENTS USING A
SERVICE IF IT HELPING OUT
ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE SAY IT'S
GOING TO DO. FINALLY THIS
PROPOSAL IS GOING TO SUPPORT A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
OUR EXISTING AND OUR REQUIRED I.
T. ASSETS. ACROSS AGENCY. WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE WE'VE EEN MORE
DEPARTMENT CENTRIC AND HOW WE
DEVELOPING MANAGER PROJECTS.
HAVING THAT WILL INFORM OUR
PRIORITIES AND OUR INVESTMENTS
AND WILL REALLY IMPROVE OUR
ABILITY TO REPORT ON PROGRESS.
AND RESULTS. VERY FOCUSED THESE
DAYS ON DELIVERING BUSINESS
VALUE IN MEASURING THAT BUSINESS
VALUE. IN DOING SO AS I SAY
RIDLEY. ULTIMATELY WHAT WILL BE
DEVELOPING IS THIS ENTERPRISE
PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT PROGRAM TO
DO THAT. IT'S GOING TO COLLECT
ORGANIZING USED DATA ABOUT OUR
EXISTING IT SOLUTIONS. IT WILL
ALSO INCLUDE A DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING PROCESSES AND
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEMATIC
WAY TO MANAGE OUR PORTFOLIO.
WILL BE ABLE THEN TO FORECAST
NEAR AND LONG TERM CAPACITY
GOING TO NEED FOR MODERNIZATION
ENHANCEMENTS AND NEW SOLUTIONS.
AND IT WILL ALLOW FOR IMPROVED
PLANNING AND PRIORITIZATION OF
IT PROJECTS IN RELATED FUNDING
REQUEST BASED BASED ON WHAT
DEPARTMENTS NEED AS WELL AS THE
AGENCY NEEDS. ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WILL DO THAT'S
CRIPPLING SAVES TIME AND MONEY
IT'S GOING TO SUPPORT EARLY
IDENTIFICATION FOR SOLUTION
RADIUS. THIS IS WHEN ONE
DEPARTMENT HAS DEVELOPED A
SOLUTION TO- IT JUST FOR CASE
MANAGEMENT OR ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION ETCETERA WE CAN
START USING THE INFORMATION FOR
CAPTURING CHIU INFORM OTHER
EFFORTS THAT NEEDS SIMILAR
CAPABILITIES AND RATHER THAN
REBUILD SOLUTIONS OR BUILD NEW
SOLUTIONS. WE CAN FOCUS ON RE
USING ARE LEVERAGING WHAT WE
HAVE. SECONDARILY WE ALSO THINK
THAT THIS WILL HELP US IMPROVE
OUR REPORTING BOTH INTERNALLY
AND EXTERNALLY WITH REGARDS TO
THE STATE OF OUR PORTFOLIO. AND
IN THE FIRST YEAR WORLD LOOKED
ESTABLISH THAT AND GET
DEPARTMENT BRIAN THE PROGRAM UP
AND STANDING. AND WILL CONFIRM
THE INPUTS AND OUTPUTS AND
PROCESSES IN THE PERFORMANCE
METRICS WE USE TO DETERMINE IF.
THE MONEY WE'RE SPENDING IS
DELIVERING THE BENEFIT WHERE
RESEARCH ASSISTANT. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THE PROPOSAL CAN HELP US
REALLY SPEND RESOURCES WHERE
THEY'RE MOST NEEDED. AND WE CAN
GIVE REALLY DELIVER THE BENEFIT
OF I. T. MORE QUICKLY AND AT
LOWER COST AND THIS WILL ALLOW
PROGRAMS TO FOCUS THEIR TIME.
AND MONEY I'M REALLY DELIVERING
THE SERVICES THEY HELP FOLKS. SO
THIS MIGHT BE HAPPENING AFTER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU. FROM
FROM YOUR LIPS TO GOD'S EARS WE
HOPE THIS WORKS US DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I THINK FOR THAT-
BELIAU. RYAN METZGER L. A. L. WE
HAVE NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL BUT ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I THINK ANYBODY WHO'S
BEEN HERE A LITTLE WHILE I WOULD
INCLUDE MYSELF AND DOCTOR PAN
HAS HEARD NOTHING BUT A PROBLEMS
WITH IT SO THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
TAKE A SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO
THAT- IS A GOOD THING SO WHEN I
T. PROJECTS. TAKE TOO LONG THAT
COST TOO MUCH DON'T FUNCTION SO
THIS ONE DEPARTMENT WILL BE IN
CHARGE OF OVERSEEING THAT VERSES
THE INDIVIDUAL PART THE
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT WHERE THE
I. T. A PROGRAM IS HOUSED IS
THAT WHAT I UNDERSTAND. NOT
QUITE IT CURRENTLY OUR OFFICE
DOES OVERSEE ALL OF THE I. T.
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE WHICH IS A
LARGE NUMBER WE TEND TO FOCUS ON
THE ONES THAT ARE MOST STRATEGIC
OF COURSE WE ALSO HAVE OUR
FRIENDS IT IT CDT CENTER. AT
DAYTON TECHNOLOGY THAT ARE
OVERSEEING OUR BIGGEST AND MOST
COMPLEX PROJECTS WITH LASTING
PARTNERSHIP. WHAT THIS SEPARATE
WILL REALLY DO IS TRY TO GET
AHEAD OF ALL THAT RIGHT SO RIGHT
NOW WE'RE OVERSEEING THESE
PROJECTS HAVE RECEIVED THESE
TRENDING ISSUES THAT WE THINK WE
CAN ADDRESS. REFORM JUST A SMALL
CADRE OF RESOURCES WITHIN. THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR OFFICE
DO YOU TO GET AHEAD OF THAT AND
PROVIDE GUIDANCE UP FRONT SO
THAT WHEN WE'RE OVERSEEING AND
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE SAME
PROBLEMS AND WE'RE PREVENTING
THE DELAYS AND THE RISKS. OKAY
SO IF WE'VE IF WE'VE SEEN A
LIGHT AND TUNNEL FOR THE
TRAINING ON A DIFFERENT PROJECT
WILL BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
SAME LIGHT. IN A DIFFERENT TIME
ALL. RIGHT WILL BE ABLE TO. IT
OKAY. DR PEPPER. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION AND
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE I DID NOT
POSE A QUESTION BECAUSE
INTERESTING ENOUGH- IN LOOKING
OVER GENDER WE HAVE- LATER ON
WE'LL BE DISCUSSING IT
DEPARTMENT WHO'S ALSO ASKING FOR
I. T. RESOURCES AND- ACTUALLY
THEY THEY ACTUALLY MADE THIS THE
LEAST AND ANALYSIS THERE'S A
STATEMENT THAT- THEY NEED. ONE
I. T. PERSON FOR EVERY TEN
WORKERS TO SUPPORT TO SUPPORT
THEIR I. T. AND SO- I COULD ASK
THEM HOW THEY CAME UP WITH THAT
NUMBER- BUT THEY'RE NOT I. T.
EXPERTS BECAUSE IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S AN AGENCY IN THIS THE PART
AND THE PART OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND THAT'S NOT THEIR
EXPERTISE. SO I GUESS THE I
QUESTION TO YOU AND MAYBE EVEN A
FOLLOW UP WITH L. A. L. IS THAT-
BECAUSE WE'RE SITTING HERE DOING
OVERSIGHT WE'RE GETTING THESE
REQUESTS. HOW DO WE EVALUATE AND
ARE YOU LOOKING AT IT AND MAYBE
THAT PRIMARY TALK TO YOU- BUT-
IN TERMS OF THE AYE IT AND
KNOWING THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
PARTS OF DIFFERENT SIZES IN A
DIFFERENT TASKS AND DIFFERENT
HAVE DIFFERENT I. T. NEEDS. IN
TERMS OF TRYING. TO ASSESS- THE
- OF- THE REQUESTS TERMS OF YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT THE LARGER
PICTURE RIGHT SO I MEAN I'M SURE
EACH DEPARTMENT AND I DON'T AND-
YOU MAYBE YOU. YEAH AND I THINK
AS YOU PRESENTED. YOU ARE
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THESE
APARTMENTS BUT A CERTAIN EXTENT
SOME OF THE PARTS OF REALLY
LARGE RIGHT AND- DAY MAY
INTERNALLY HAVE THEIR OWN IT
JUST LIKE. THE EIGHTY JUST IS
REALLY LARGE HAS YOUR
DEPARTMENT. AND THEN WE HAVE FOR
THE WHOLE STATE GOVERNMENT WITH
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY SO WE
REALIZE A DIFFERENT LAYERS. THAT
SO MAYBE CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW THE PLAYERS ARE
COORDINATED IN TERMS OF.
DETERMINING THAT WHETHER WE HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE I. T. SUPPORT
FOR EACH OF THE DIFFERENT.
AGENCIES AND FUNCTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT- PARTICULARLY RELATED
TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OF
KNOWING THAT ONE OF YOUR
AGENCIES LATER ON WILL BE
PRESENTED TO US REQUESTING SOME
IT. SUPPORT WHICH YOU KNOW I.
LOOKED FINE AND I'M SURE L. A.
L. GIVES THEIR OPINION THAT MORE
ANALYZE OPINIONS. BUT I ALSO
WONDERED. HOW THAT YOU'RE FACED
WITH YOUR REQUEST HERE. YEAH YES
SIR THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
A ONE TO TEN RATIO THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS GENERALLY USED
FOR AT THE- CORE IT SUPPORT NET
INVOICING STAFF WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT NEED IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE I. T. PROJECTS THAT
ARE OFTEN INCREMENTAL TO THAT.
OKAY SO NINE ONE TO TEN IS THIS
IS KIND OF LIKE A STANDARD THE
THAT- GENDER SO I COULD GET
BECAUSE I KNOW I JUST SAW THAT
AND WHAT. WE'RE THAT COME FROM
SOUTH AFRICA RIGHT INTO ITS
DEPARTMENTS GROWING GET MORE
PEOPLE THEY NEED MORE I. T.
STAFF AT THE END THAT IS THE
STANDARD THAT. THAT I BELIEVE
DOCTORS USED AS WELL. OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL I MEAN IT'S ALSO
INTERESTING TO THINK THAT MEANS
EVERY TIME WE GROW TEN PEOPLE TO
DO WHATEVER FRONT LINE WORK WE
NEED. WE THEN HAVE ANOTHER YOU
KNOW AFTER AND I DEEPER SO
REALLY THAT COMES ELEVEN RIGHT
AND THEN. RECOGNIZING OF COURSE
DEPENDING ON THE NATURE OF THE
WORK AND I THINK THERE'S OF
COURSE OTHER TYPES OF PEOPLE
THEY NEED AS ALL OTHER TYPES OF
SUPPORT AS WELL AND- I CHAU
NODDING THEIR HEADS SO YOU AGREE
AS WELL. ALL THREE D. AGREE- ONE
MY COLLEAGUES BE ADDRESSED. THAT
A PROPOSAL LATER ON IN THE JETTA
SO. HOPEFULLY THEY CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON THAT ONE. OKAY WELL
I THIS IS A MORE OF AN I. T.
QUESTION I THOUGHT IT ASK IT NOW
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE THE I. T.
EXPERTS VERSES. ASKING AN
AGENCY- THAT. MY VIEWS THE
STANDARD THAT THEY'RE FAMILIAR
WITH BUT WOULDN'T AND THAT'S
REALLY NOT THE JUSTIFICATION
BECAUSE- THEIR- THEIR MAIN TASK
IS. NOT HIGH T. CELL OKAY. RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO. TO TO ANSWER MY QUESTION AND
SET TO TOUCH ON THAT- BUT
THERE'S- I THINK THE CHAIR
MENTIONED. WE GET TASKED WITH
OVERSEEING- AND I WILL BE VERY
CLEAR ACTUALLY. THE PROBLEM WITH
IT PROJECTS IS THAT. WHEN THEY
DON'T WORK THAT'S WHEN THEY HIT
THE NEWS SO USUALLY THE NEWS IS
JUST LIKE YOU KNOW AND THEY'RE
COMPLICATED. WHEN THEY DO WORK.
PEOPLE TO DOESN'T MAKE THE NEWS
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF IT
PROJECTS ACTUALLY WORK THEM
FAMILIAR WITH IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. I ALSO KNOW IF YOU
THAT DIDN'T WORK AND GET THE
NEWS. SO WE'D LIKE TO KEEP THE
I. T. OUT OF THE NEWS. THAT'S.
WHERE THAT WAY I THINK
EVERYONE'S HAPPIER THAT WAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU AGAIN. AS THE
DIRECTOR WORKING FOR THAT A
PRESENTATION. VERY INFORMATIVE.
OKAY MOVING ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER
FOR SOME TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS-
THAT WILL BE. A DIRECTOR OF
MUSTAPHA JONES WELCOME DIRECTOR
. AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MELISSA
STAFFORD JONES DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
THESE. TWO ITEMS WITH RESPECT TO
BE OUR PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
AND THE TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING
FOR EDUCATORS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE LOSE PROJECTS IS WELL
UNDERWAY. AND LED THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
AND THEY ANTICIPATE THAT
CONTRACTS WILL BE READY TO BE
PUT IN PLACE TO SUPPORT THE
EXECUTION OF THAT WORK EARLY IN
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. SO THIS I
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT WOULD ALLOW
FOR THAT WORK TO PROCEED IT THE
SCOPE AND DEVELOP AND IS OUT
WELL UNDER WAY AND IT AND
PROCESS. WITH THE SECOND ITEM
RELATED TO FUNDING WITH IN
CALLIE TAKE JUST RELATED TO OUR
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE AND THE
EVALUATION AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE EXPENDITURES WILL VARY
OVER TIME SO ONE OF THE THINGS
WORKING VERY HARD ON RIGHT NOW
IS. THE DEVELOPMENT OF A SCOPE
OF WORK FOR OUR EVALUATION
PARTNER AND SO WILL I HAVE HAVE
FUNDS THAT RELATE TO ULTIMATELY
SERVE THE KHITANS OF THAT
EVALUATION AND SO HAVING THIS
ABILITY TO UTILIZE THE FUNDS
OVER TIME THAT MATCH THE SCOPE
OF THE WORK IN THE EVALUATION
AND THE ENGAGEMENT SUBJECT
MATTER. EXPERTS IS WHAT. THANK
VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
FOR THE ILIO. I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THE START PARA NADA
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
DIRECTORS DEBRA JONES- LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION- DIRECTED CHAU
HOW WE'RE- GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS THANK YOU WELL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE AND
ADDRESS- AB I WILL BUDGET ITEMS
WITH YOU. I HAVE TODAY WITH ME
MARK ALL OF THE MEN WHO WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT OUR HOUSE WAS
BRAND AND THAT JUST THE GROWTH
WILL TALK ABOUT OUR OKAY WHAT
THE NATION OF I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A FEW MINUTES. A MOMENT OR
TWO AND JUST SHARE SOME
FOUNDATION ALL. I'M SOME
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW DO WE APPROACH THE PROJECTS
THAT WOULD THAT WORK FOR YOU
TODAY SO. AT THE FARM AND THAT
THAT IS REALLY STARTING BUT THE
BELIEF THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES
EXCEPTION NONE. HAVE TRULY BE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEANINGFUL OF
ONE. M. F. AN ESSENTIAL ELEMENT
OF THAT IS KNOWING AND DOT
INFORMED AS SUCH- AND PORTMAN
HELLO ARE OF HEALTH AND- AS OUR
AGENCY HAS DONE SO MUCH WORK ON
THAT FUNDING SHORING THAT. I'M
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF THE WHOLE
PERSON IT BECOMES. REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE MAXIMIZING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
INDIVIDUALS UPSTREAM IN THE
BUILDING I'M IMPORTANT ONE. SO
HERE THE OTHER THING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE LIVED
REPRESENTATION. IN THE VARIOUS
INITIATIVES IN VARIOUS PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE I THINK IT WILL GO
A BIT ABOUT IN OUR- FEELING THE
MISSION OF. THIS AFTERNOON. AND
THEN OF COURSE ONE OF THE THINGS
I'M BUT WE ALSO GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION JAIL IS HOW DO WE
BRING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. IN A
GALLOP FEDERAL DOLLARS. AND EVEN
BETTER DOLLARS THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE GENERAL FUND MATCH THE
GRANT THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
DAY. DOES EXACTLY THAT. SO WE'LL
LOOK FOR JOE ANSWERED ME AND
THIS HEALTH QUESTIONS OF YOUR
HAVE ALSO THOUGHT MIGHT MONEY
OVER VIEW OF HERE AND CHORE OVER
TO MARK TO. COVER OUR PATH WAS
BENT FORGET SO MARK. THANK YOU
JOE- AND GOOD AFTERNOON- BUT I'M
SURE AND SENATOR PAN AM JOE
MANCHIN MONEY'S MARC GROSSMAN
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES DIVISION
HERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
OVERVIEW OF OUR PATH TO SUCCESS
PROGRAM. LAST SPRING THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION POSTED A
SOLICITATION FOR PROPOSALS FOR
HIS MILLION INPATIENT FUND
GRANTS. STABLE CATION RELOCATION
AGENCIES WERE ENCOURAGED TO
APPLY FOR THIS FIVE YEAR GRANT
FOR UP TO A TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN
POINT THREE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. LIFE IS COMPETITIVE
BRANDON THIS PAST SEPTEMBER. WE
LEARNED THAT WE WERE AWARDED THE
FULL RENT AMOUNT EIGHTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION TO IMPLEMENT THE
PATHWAY TO SUCCESS PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION RATE OF
INDIVIDUALS DISABILITIES IN HIGH
WAGE HIGH SKILL AND HIGH DEMAND
CAREERS INCLUDING THOSE IN
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
MATHEMATICS. THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SEX AND WE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SECTOR
SPECIALIST TEAMS THAT I'VE BEEN
TRAINING TOOLS KNOWLEDGE AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT IN SELECTED SECTORS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY MIGHT LET. IN
PARTICULAR THIS PROGRAM IS
TARGETED AT UNDERREPRESENTED
INDIVIDUALS OF THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN IN
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. AND
YOU FOUND THAT CHEN NOTED DR
JONES THEY WERE NOTED THE
FEDERAL WAR DOES NOT REQUIRE
STATE MATCH. PROGRAM DESIGNED
PROJECTS INTERVENTION EVALUATION
PLAN WHERE ALL THE FINAL DETAILS
IN OUR PROGRAM PROPOSAL IN
DETAIL THE WORK WE'RE PERFORMING
TEMPLATE THIS PROJECT. OUR
OVERARCHING GOAL IN THIS
INNOVATIVE PROJECT IS TESTING
NEW SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL.
COLLECTION EVALUATE PERFORMANCE
AND OUTCOME DATA TO SEE HOW THE
MODEL IMPACT VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION CONSUMERS AS OUTCOMES
. ENSURE THAT INFORMATION
NATIONALLY- THE NEW YORK WILL
COLLECT DEMOGRAPHIC BACKGROUND
IN CASE INFORMATION ON
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PARTICIPATING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. SHARE WITH AN
EVALUATION PARTNER TO FULFIL THE
AWARDS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THIS WILL INCLUDE TRACKING
SERVICE DELIVERY PROTESTS IN
PROGRESS AND MONITORING
PERFORMANCE INCLUDING MOST
IMPORTANTLY EMPLOYMENT OUTCOME
DATA FOR PARTICIPANTS. WE DID
RECEIVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THE FIRST
ONE IS PLEASE DESCRIBE THE WORK
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY
COMPLETED IN SUPPORT OF PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. AS NOTED- WE'RE
JUST OVER HALFWAY THROUGH THE
FIRST YEAR OF THIS FIVE YEAR
GRANT FUNDED PROJECT WHICH BEGAN
IN OCTOBER FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THEREFORE PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES HAVE BEEN CENTERED ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM DESIGN AND SETTING UP ON
THE EVALUATION. SO FAR WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE FOLLOWING
ACTIVITIES NEGOTIATED
IMPLEMENTED A MULTI YEAR
CONTRACT THE PROJECT EVALUATOR
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PARTNER
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
WE'VE OBTAINED INSTITUTIONAL
REVIEW BOARD APPROVAL FOR THE
PROJECT EVALUATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
HUMAN SUBJECTS. COMPLETED
RECRUITMENT AND SELECTED EIGHT
SECTOR SPECIALIZATION TEAM
STAFF. WHAT BEGUN IDENTIFYING
AND ENROLLING PARTICIPANTS AND
CONTACTING SECTOR SPECIFIC
EMPLOYERS. AS OF NINE AM THIS
MORNING- WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
ALREADY MORE AND ROLLED NINETY
NINE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS. WE
DEVELOPED IMPLEMENTED TRACKING
SYSTEMS TO IDENTIFY PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS OF SERVICES
PROVIDED IN AN EXPENDITURE
RELATED TO THE GRANT. WE DEVELOP
SCOPE OF WORK FOR CONTRACTS WITH
OUR TWO TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS WHICH ARE
STANFORD NEURODIVERSITY AND
UCLA'S TARJAN CENTER. WITHIN THE
ANTICIPATED CONTRACT START DATE
OF JULY FIRST. THIS YEAR. I'M
FINE WITH COMPLETED DRAFTS OF
MARKETING MATERIALS FOR
DISTRIBUTION TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
FOR BUSINESS PARTNERS. IN FACT
EVEN THOUGH WE JUST STARTED I'M
REALLY PROUD TO SAY THAT WE'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED MOVING THANK
YOU CARD FROM ONE OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS WAS WORKING WITH A
WONDERFUL CONCERT SUPPORTING THE
HEALTH CARE SECTOR TEAM- THE
OTHER QUESTION I WOULD HAVE
RESPONDED IS. HOW WILL THE
DEPARTMENT MEASURES SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM. AS NOTED THIS IS A
IN RESEARCH GRANTS- SO THE GOLD-
IN SO WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE BALL OF. AS THE PARTICIPANTS
THE PARTICIPATION RATE AND
EMPLOYMENT OF THOSE INDIVIDUAL
DISABILITIES IN HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
LUCKY PATIENTS SUCH AS THOSE
FOUND. SO WITH SPECIFIC MEASURES
OUR SUCCESS IN THESE ARE DETAIL
IN OUR SUCCESSFUL GRANT
APPLICATION. ON THESE APPS
MEASURES REALLY ARE BASED ON THE
IMPACT THAT THE SERVICES WERE
PROVIDING ON THE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED PROPOSED PROJECT
PARTICIPANTS. THESE INCLUDE OUR
PARTICIPANTS ACHIEVEMENT OF
MEASURABLE SKILLS GAINES
COMPLETION OF THEIR TRAINING.
ENTRY INTO A COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT ENTRY INTO
HIGH WAGE HIGH SKILL EMPLOYMENT
. AND THE NUMBER OF HOURS WORKED
FOR A FIRM PREVIOUSLY EMPLOYED
APPLICANTS. ARE PARTICIPANTS
INCREASE IN EARNINGS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE EMPLOYED
AND- AND OTHER NON HIGHWAYS
EMPLOYMENT- RECEIVE A FOR PAY
BENEFITS. AND THE REDUCTION OF
RELIANCE ON PUBLIC BENEFITS-
EXCITED THIS PROJECT THE
POSSIBILITIES POSSIBILITIES IT
PRESENTS TO IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CONSUMERS WITH DISABILITIES
AND EMPLOYERS LOOKING FOR
QUALIFIED TALENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
THIS PROJECT AND FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN IT. I'D BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS I HAVE MANY
MITCHELL OF BIG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WE JUST
WANTED TO ADD REALLY QUICKLY
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
NOTIFICATION- OF THE INCREASE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE LEGISLATURE
NORMALLY THE PROCEDURE THAT WE
WOULD FOLLOW IS TO DO A SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT NOTIFICATION-
RECORDS AT THE SAME TIME- THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT ALREADY HAS THE
EXPENDITURE THIRDS MAJORITY IN
THE CURRENT YEAR AND THEN WE
WOULD DO A SECTION TWENTY EIGHT-
TO INCREASE EXPENDITURES ALREADY
AM UNFORTUNATELY AT THE TIME.
THAT WE WERE I AM RECEIVING THIS
GRAND AND ANALYZING IT WE WAS
ALSO THE SAME TIME THAT WE COULD
RELEASE THIS B. C. P. AND SO
THIS IS THE FIRST NOTIFICATION
BUT WE JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON
WIRE. THIS IS THE FORM THAT WE
ARE NOTIFYING ONLINE. THANK YOU.
HELLO AS ANY PARTICULAR THE L.
A. O. NO- COMMENTS IN PARTICULAR
ON THE PROPOSAL AND THE ONE
THING WE HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
MISTER BAKER JUST ADDRESSED SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER LITTMAN.
DID DID WE WORK WITH THE ARE A
OUR UNIVERSITY. PARTNERS TO ALSO
SET UP THE- OUR OUTCOME MEASURES
LIKE HOW TO HOW DO WE KNOW WE
SUCCEEDED ASSEMBLY COMPLETING A
PROGRAM GETTING EMPLOYMENT WHAT
ARE THE OUTCOMES MEASURES LOOK
LIKE. YES WE ACTUALLY WORK WITH
OUR UNIVERSITY PARTNER IN THE
DEVELOPMENT THE GRANT AND THERE
WAS A PRETTY RIGID- EVALUATION
COMPONENT REQUIREMENT OF THE
GRANT APPLICATION. IN A REALLY
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE AT THE
ACTUAL THE PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES
THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY SIMILAR TO
OUR OUTCOMES OR OUR GENERAL
CONSUMERS AND- BECAUSE WE WORK
WITH OUTSIDE OF THIS GRANT- BUT
THEY ARE. THEY ARE MORE ROBUST
THAN THEIR MORE AMBITIOUS AND
THESE INCLUDE- WHERE SOMEBODY
ENTERING INTO A COLLEGE THAT
TRAIN PROGRAM DO THEY-
MATRICULATION THE PROGRAM. AND
DO THEY GRADUATE- IF- DO THEY
ENTER INTO EMPLOYMENT AND IS SO
IS IT IN THERE EMPLOYMENT GOAL
OF CHOICE. AND ARE THEY
RECEIVING THE FULL BENEFITS OF
EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT FULL TIME WORK AND
COMPETITIVE WAGES AND- BENEFITS
. OKAY SO IN ESSENCE IT'S A REAL
EVALUATION NOT JUST OF THE
PARTICIPANT BUT ALSO OF THE- THE
PROVISION OF SERVICES THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT IN ORDER FOR THAT
PERSON TO BE SUCCESSFUL CORRECT.
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE WE HI AND- AND
WE'RE TRACKING ALL SPECIFIC
SERVICES AND INTERVENTIONS THAT
EACH INDIVIDUAL GAS. AND TRACK
THE OUTCOMES AND SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY HOPE WELL WE HAVE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY- TO- DETERMINE
WHICH OF THE SERVICE
INTERVENTIONS- MAY PROVE TO BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL- BUT ULTIMATELY-
YOU KNOW THESE THESE ARE TIED
INTO- TO. BE INDIVIDUAL SUCCESS
AND SO WEBER HOPING THAT THE
COMBINATION OF SERVICES RESULT
IN THAT SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME BUT
WE DO OPERATE WE ARE TRACKING IN
YOUR- OWN NOTING. EACH OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS- THAT THE SERVICES
THAT THEY RECEIVED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYTHING DR. THIS
REVIEW THE WORK BEING DONE WITH
THE FOR THE RESULTS THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT- THE
PRESENTATION. OKAY MOVING ON TO
ISSUE A NUMBER TWO THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT IS THAT GOING TO BE-
MISTER EXAM OR MISTER ERIC MANN.
HELP JESSICA CROWBAR DEPUTY FOR
POLICY WILL WILL PRESENT ON THAT
SUCH AS THE CALLS AND IT'S YEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU THINK JESSICA.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
JESSICA GROWTH. ON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT DO OUR OR OUR
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION POLICY
RESOURCES DIVISION- I'M REALLY
HONORED TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
TODAY ON AND ON THIS INITIATIVE
WE'RE CALLING IT THE AND
INTEGRATING EMPLOYMENTS IN
RECOVERY. AND DEAL ARE IS ASKING
FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. FOR A
PROJECT THAT WILL AND THAT ONE
CORPORATE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
INTO RECOVERY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AS
JOE EXAME YOUR MENTIONED EARLIER
I'M- AT IMPLEMENT HAS BEEN BEEN
PROVEN TO BE A SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND- IN
THE TREATMENT OF A FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DISABILITIES. IT SHOWN TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND- REDUCTION OF
VISITS TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND- AT LAST FREQUENTED YOUR
HOSPITALIZATION LESS INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THERE
ARE A LOT OF PROVEN BENEFITS. OF
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT AND
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORTS IN RECOVERY.
AND THIS- PROJECT WILL ALLOW US
TO DO THE SAME WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER I HAVE A PERSONAL
CONNECTION TO THIS PROJECT
MYSELF I AM A PERSON IN
RECOVERY- I'M UP UNTIL EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO I WAS AT DAILY USER OF
ILLICIT OPIOIDS. AND AND I'M
REALLY AGAIN LIKE I SAID. I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY TO PRESENT ON THIS
PROJECT. THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
COME. TO THE WORK I'M ONE.
PROVIDING EDUCATE. TO THE-
PROVIDER WORK FORCE SO WE'RE
INTERESTED IN DEVELOPING%
CURRICULUM THAT CAN BE USED
WITHOUT EMERGING AT PROVIDER
WORK FORCE. TO HELP THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS OF
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT IN RECOVERY
AND ALSO PROVIDE INFORMATION ON
THE VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION OR
VR SYSTEM ON THE OTHER WORKFORCE
PARTNERS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
HELP THE INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR
SERVING. AS DAY- AS THEY
COMPLETE TREATMENT AND EITHER
I'M LOOK FOR WORK OR RETURN TO-
TO PREVIOUS EMPLOYMENT. SO THAT
COMPONENT OF THE INITIATIVE-
WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TOWARDS
THE STAFFING FOR BOTH THE
DEVELOPING AND THEN FOR THE
DELIVERY. OF THOSE TRAININGS THE
SECOND PIECE OF THE PROPOSAL IS
AND TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND THIS IS TO PILOT
WITH FOR TREATMENT CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE IN BETTING VIA
OUR PROFESSIONAL STAFF INTO
THOSE CENTERS AS MEMBERS OF THE
TREATMENT TEAM. TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES A WHILE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RECEIVING- OTHER
TREATMENT SERVICES AT THE SAME
TIME AND TO BE ABLE TO- TO
HIGHER. INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE- WHO ARE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT IN THE AREAS A IN THE-
FOR THE POPULATIONS THAT THEY'LL
BE SERVING AND SO THAT PIECE OF
IT IS- IS TO EMBED BOTH. WHAT WE
CALLED QUALIFIED REHABILITATION
PROFESSIONALS REHABILITATION
COUNSELOR AS WELL AS AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK AS PART OF THE TREATMENT
TEAM. TO SUPPORT- EMPLOYMENT
SKILLS AND SO OF COURSE OF THOSE
IN THE WHO ARE GOING TO
TREATMENT. I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED IN
ADVANCE ON THE FIRST IS THE
FUNDING BREAKDOWN FOR THE TO
PURPOSES AND SO AS I'VE
INDICATED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AS TOWARDS THE TRAINING
COMPONENT FOR THE PROVIDER WORK
FORCE AND THE TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR INVITING
STAFF INTO- INTO TREATMENT
CENTERS TO PROVIDE B. R.
SERVICES. AS PART OF A TREATMENT
TEAM. THE SECOND QUESTION. WAS
REGARDING. WHEN THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS THE PROGRAM TO BEGIN
OPERATING. FOR THE TRAINING
COMPONENT OUR INTENTION IS TO
BEGIN RECRUITING RIGHT AWAY AND
DEVELOPING THE CURRICULUM WITH
THE- WITH THE GOAL OF BEGINNING
TO DELIVER THOSE TRAININGS TO
THAT MARGIN WORK FORCE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THOSE TRAININGS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
THREE YEARS. THAT YEAH EMBEDDING
OF THE STAFF AND THE EMPLOYMENT
CENTERS I'M SORRY IN THE
TREATMENT CENTERS- FOR THAT
COMPONENT WE ARE EXPECTING TO
FINALIZE THE TREATMENT CENTERS
THAT WILL RECEIVE THOSE STAFF
MEMBERS BY AROUND SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AND THEN BEGIN TO ACTUALLY CO
LOCATE STAFF THERE IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR TWO OF
THE CENTERS- AND THEN LEARNING
FROM FROM- THE FIRST CHIU
CENTERS CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY TWO
ADDITIONAL CENTERS. ON AND THAT
THE STAFF. IN APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THE LAST QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE WAS REGARDING HOW
WE WOULD SELECT THE CENTERS THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD PARTICIPATE IN
A PILOT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- AS AS AGAIN DRUG DURING
SAVE YOUR SPOKE ABOUT- AND AS
I'VE HEARD THROUGH SOME OF THE
EARLIER PRESENTATIONS
REPRESENTATION. MATTERS WE WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE'RE
CHOOSING TREATMENT CENTERS THAT
REFLECT VARIED EXPERIENCE
WHETHER THAT BE- INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE- POPULATIONS THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED.
OR PERHAPS YOU HAVE BEEN ON. WHO
HAVE BEEN- EXCUSE ME I'M- WHO
WHO REALLY EXPERIENCED AND BEEN
DEVASTATED BY THE OPIOID CRISIS
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CHOOSE
TREATMENT CENTERS I'M TO REFLECT
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE GREATEST
NEED. AND SO WE'D LIKE TO DO
THAT WITH- A THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
I'M SEEKING OUT THOSE CENTERS
WHERE INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT HAVE
RECEIVED FULL SERVICES IN OTHER
WAYS AND PUT OUR STAFF THERE AND
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO HIRE
STAFF WHO ARE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT IN SERVING THOSE
POPULATIONS AND WITH THE
INTENTION OF HAVING THEM BE
THEMSELVES AS A PEER SUPPORT SO
AS A MEMBER OF THE TREATMENT
TEAM BUT ALSO SOMEONE THAT CAN
GAIN THE TRUST OF THE
INDIVIDUALS IN RECOVERY. AND
SPEAK TO THEM FROM AN INFORMED
POSITION ANOTHER IMPORTANT
COMPONENT FOR US BEING THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
INTERESTED IN EMPLOYMENT IS
INVITING STAFF IN DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT HAVE A TO. EMPLOYMENT
LANDSCAPE SO WE WOULD WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE WE'RE
TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO FOR EXAMPLE ARE
IN A RURAL SETTING OR THE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES ARE
VERY DIFFERENT PERHAPS THAN AS
TREATMENT CENTER THAT MAY BE IN
A METROPOLITAN AREA WHERE THERE
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER TYPES OF
EMPLOYMENT AND DIFFERENCES IN
THE NECESSARY SUPPORT SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION- AT AND THE OTHER
COMPONENTS THAT GO ALONG WITH.
EMPLOYMENT AND WITH WORK
EXPERIENCE. I'M WITH I WILL HOW
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE PRINTER TO
GROW FROM WERE ALSO VERY GLAD
THAT YOU'RE HERE ON ON THIS
ISSUE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BAKER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING THAT AT THIS
TIME HALFPENNY AS ANY QUESTIONS
OF THANK YOU SPITAK. THANK YOU
SENATE HEADED FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
JUST HAVE ONE- FAIRLY MINOR
COMMENT ABOUT THAT HI THE
PROPOSED PILOT PROGRAMS FOR THE
SECOND PIECE OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AND THAT IS- YOUR HAS INDICATED
THAT- THAT HAS NOT QUITE WORKED
OUT YET HOW WOULD YOU EVALUATE
THIS NOVEL- PILOT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S- WHETHER IT'S A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL THAT AND WHEN
THE COULD BE SORT OF REPLICATED
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE- IN
THE CONVERSATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
INDICATED. TO US THAT IT IS
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS
AND THAT IT'S YOU KNOW KIND OF A
NUANCED ISSUE- HOWEVER AS
WRITTEN THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY MENTION OF AN
EVALUATION AND SO THERE IS
CONSEQUENTLY NO WAY TO GUARANTEE
THAT ONE WOULD BE CONDUCTED. AND
OUR OFFICE THINGS THIS WOULD BE
SORT OF A MISSED OPPORTUNITY AND
WE SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ADDING A REQUIREMENT
WERE IT TO APPROVED THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK AYE
SEE MS GROVE NODDING SO WOULD
YOU AGREE THAT AN EVALUATION
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
OF THIS. THANK YOU I WAS
WONDERING IF I IF I MAY RESPOND.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND YES I AM IT IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT. FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE V. R. SITE. AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE. AN INCLUDED IN
MEASUREMENTS. FOR THAT YOU KNOW
FOR THE TRAINING COMPONENT- OF
COURSE HOW MANY PEOPLE RECEIVED
THIS TRAINING. I AM AND- THEN
AND THEN. THE FRIEND THAT FOR
THE IN BATTING THERE THE STAFF
INTO THE TREATMENT CENTERS.
THERE ARE SOME SOME SIMPLE. OF
MEASURABLE SUCH AS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVED
SERVICES WHAT TYPES OF SERVICES
DID THEY RECEIVINGA LENGTH OF
TIME THAT THEY DEAD. HOW MANY
AND SHE THEIR WORK EXPERIENCE
HOW MANY- ARE EMPLOYED AT THE
RESOLUTION OF THEIR TREATMENTS
HEY. I'M WOULD LOVE TO- DO SOME
FOLLOW UP AS WELL WHERE POSSIBLE
AND TO SEE IF PEOPLE ARE
RETAINING EMPLOYMENT HOW THEY'RE
DOING UP TO NINE MONTHS AFTER.
TREATMENTS I'M- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FEEL WE MAY
HAVE IS N. FOLLOW UP WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN TREATMENT
AS AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW. AND
TREATMENT. TYPICALLY DOESN'T
FOLLOW A LINEAR PATH FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS AGES IT MAY BE
SOMETHING WITH STARTS AND STOPS.
AND THESE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES-
CAN PROVIDE AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
THAT WHOLE AND THAT CONNECTION
TO STAY ENGAGE WITH RECOVERY
EVEN ENOUGH. IT'S NOT MOVES ON
AND WITHOUT FUNDS SO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT WE THINK COULD
BE BENEFICIAL BUT WE DO REALLY.
NEED TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THOSE TREATMENT TEAMS ARE
LOOKING NOT HOW LONG SOMEONE
STAYS ENGAGED IN TREATMENT. CAN
WE MAKE A DIFFERENCE BY OFFERING
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES EARLY AND
SUCCESSFULLY WELL THAT KEEPS
THEM ON. ENROLLED IN TREATMENT
WILL THAT HAVE A DIFFERENCE ON
HOW LONG THEY STAY ENGAGED IN
AFTER CARE. SO WE AGREED THAT
THAT MEASUREMENT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
WE'RE I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE THAT AND SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. OKAY I DO THINK
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT I DO
UNDERSTAND NUANCES BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
REALLY IN AND WORKING WELL WITH
ANY POPULATION ESPECIALLY AROUND
THE ABILITY SHIN. IS ON-
RELATIONSHIP AND ENGAGEMENT- AND
SO THEN I WOULD ALSO WONDER
PLACES WHERE YOU'RE A BETTING
PEOPLE WILL THERE BE A LEVEL OF
EVALUATION. ALL FOR EXISTING
STAFF ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE OF
HAVING EMBEDDED PEOPLE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION. AS
PART OF THAT EVALUATION. YEAH I
THINK IT'S THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK ACROSS THE SPECTRUM MET
THIS BECAUSE THE IDEA HERE IS
TO. DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY AND
APPROACH THAT WE CAN. HOPE TO
SCALE ACROSS YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR
PROGRAM. SO YES WILL LOOK TO DO
THE JOB KEEP IN MIND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH OTHER
PARTNERS- AND OBVIOUSLY WILL.
HAVE THEIR BY IAN AND IN DOING
THIS AS WELL. THE REPLICATION IS
ALWAYS THE GOAL OF IF IT'S
SUCCESSFUL ON A REPLICA OF
SINGLE LIKE THAT AREN'T WORKING
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT IN
RETURNING THIS PROJECT THE IDEA
OF LOOKING AT THE WHOLE PERSON.
AND GOING UPSTREAM AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE WE REALLY HOPE. AND
BELIEVE THIS WILL CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY FROM THAT FOR THEM IN
THE LONG TERM- KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT POINTS. IT'S JUST A
REALLY I THINK A KEY THING TO BE
TAKING ACTUALLY TWO PEOPLE IN
WHILE IN RECOVERY- AND I AND I
GUESS I WOULD JUST WONDER. ABOUT
THE AVAIL. OF TREATMENT CENTERS
AND SOME OF OUR MORE RURAL AREAS
THAT WE KNOW HAVE BEEN HARDEST
HIT WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS. IF
THEY EVEN HAVE TREATMENT TO
START WITH TO IN BED- SOMEBODY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT IN THERE SO
I THINK THOSE THINGS WILL NEED
TO BE LOOKED AT AN ONGOING BASIS
GOING FORWARD. THIRTY PAN
ANYTHING ON THIS NOW OKAY THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH IMPORTANT WORK
IN THEM I'M GLAD WHERE WE'RE
TAKING IT ON. OKAY MOVING ON TO
OUR NEXT ISSUE- EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IS. CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE DATA
RESOURCE SYSTEM FUNDING
REAPPROPRIATION OVER HERE FROM
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR LOUIS
ROOKIE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR PARA. I AM
LUIS FRANKIE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY WHICH
WE WILL WORK FOR TO S. M. SET.
AS REQUESTED A WRITTEN TRUSSELL
ADAMS IS CHIEF MINISTRATION WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR
THREE PROPOSALS UNDER
CONSIDERATION. WELCOME L.
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES HI MY
NAME'S OUR TRUST ON THE JEEP OF
ADMINISTRATION AND ENDS UP OUR
FIRST PROPOSAL IS THE CALIFORNIA
MERCY MEDICAL SERVICES DATA
RESOURCE SYSTEM FUNDING
REAPPROPRIATION. MS ARE
REQUESTING IS REQUESTING THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING
CONFERENCE FOR EXPENDITURE THIS
FUNDING UNTIL JUNE. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- THIS IS NEEDED TO
CONTINUE TO COMPLETE THE PROJECT
PLANNING PROCESS FOR THE CEDARS.
OUR SYSTEM TO INCREASE DATA
OPERATE INTER OPERABILITY
BETWEEN HOSPITALS EMS AGENCIES
AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
CONTINUITY OF CARE CURRENTLY
DON'T COVER AREAS OF THE STATE-
THE RE APPROPRIATIONS NECESSARY
DUE TO PROJECT DELAYS STAFFING
RECRUITMENT ISSUES AND ONGOING
OVERSEE RESPONSE EFFORTS IN THE
AFFECTS OF COPING NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. DURING TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. OUR
PROCESS IS AN ONBOARDING THE
WHIMS IS TO THE PLUS YOU KNOW
SYSTEM IS EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. ADDITIONALLY
CHAPTER ONE FORTY THREE
STRETCHES OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OR EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE ALSO
REQUIRES AN THAT IMPLEMENT
CEDARS IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
PHYSICIAN ORDERS FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT OR POLLS
REGISTRY- HAS THE REGISTRIES FOR
POTENTIAL WILL BE REALIZED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CEDARS- AB ONE THIRTY THREE ALSO
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR THE
REGISTRY THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH
THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALIGN WITH THE
TIMING OF WHEN THE LINE TRYING
TO BOTH PROJECTS.
REAPPROPRIATION FUNDING WILL
ALSO PROVIDE FOR THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE POWER PROCESS
PROCEDURES PROJECT THE
ONBOARDING ADDITIONAL ONES AS TO
A PLUS IN MY SYSTEM. NEARLY
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS CALL FOR
MERCY MEDICAL SERVICES EACH
STANDARDIZED EMS DATA SHARE VIA
POP INFORMATION EXCHANGE. IS
IMPROVE MEDICAL CARE. FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS IMPLEMENTATION OF
SEARS ALL OUT FOR THE EMERGENCY
CARE SEAMLESSLY TRANSITION FROM
YOUNG ASKED. THE HOSPITAL STAFF
AND BEYOND. THE END OF THE OVER
HERE THIRTY QUESTIONS. I THINK
JUST GO ON TO THE THREE ISSUES
IN THIS OF UP YOU'RE DOING ALL
THREE OF US THANK YOU I PROPOSAL
NUMBER TWOS INCREASED RESOURCES
FOR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
MISSION EFFICIENCY. MS IS
REQUESTING TWO POSITIONS AND
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THREE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AN ONGOING.
QUESTED STAFFING RESOURCE
ALLOWANCE AT A MANAGE GROWTH IN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STAFFING.
AND ADDRESS SECURITY
DEFICIENCIES TO MEET MS AS
CURRENT LONG TERM IT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. ONE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALIST TWO POSITIONS
REQUESTED AND WILL SERVE AS THE
ASSISTANT INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER RESPONSIBLE FOR SECURITY
OPERATIONS FOR CLOUD COMPUTING
ONE PREMISES COMPUTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FORMER REALLY
SCANNING AND OTHER INFORMATION
SECURITY DUTIES. IN THOSE ONLY
ISO POSITION RIGHT NOW IS OFF IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SECURITY
POLICIES STATE SECURITY POLICY
COMPLIANCE RISK MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGY RECOVERY. WHEN THEIR
REQUEST FOR SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS OR SECURITY
FORENSICS COMPLETION OF THESE
REQUEST MAY BE DELAYED AND OR
COMPLETED IF THE COST OF NOT
PERFORMING BETTER INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DUTIES. NOT
ADDRESSING KNOWN VULNERABILITIES
REMEDIATION REQUIREMENTS AND NOT
HAVING PROPER INFORMATION
SECURITY RESOURCES WILL RESULT
IN THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
STRUCTURE BEING COMPROMISED
NAMES. OPERATIONS AFFECTED AS A
RESULT. THIS POSITION IS ON THE
IN FRONT FROM OUR SUPPORT.
MISSION WHICH IS BEING REQUESTED
AND WILL PROVIDE DAILY THING FOR
STRUCTURE OPERATIONS OVERSIGHT
MANAGEMENT AS MS THIS MISSION.
RAISED IN THE OFFICE OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY OR A
WHITE SHE GROWS AS A RESULT ALL
RIGHTY CURRENTLY ONLY HAS ONE
MANAGER ON STAFF. ARE GROWING
FROM HLP DESK TO A FULL SERVICE
ENTERPRISE LEVEL IT
ORGANIZATION- I. T. EASY REALIGN
TO THREE ENTITIES IT
INFRASTRUCTURE OPERATIONS
PROGRAM SUPPORT AND INFORMATION
SECURITY. ADDITIONAL LEADERSHIP
IS ALSO NECESSARY TO HELP
OVERSEE IT INFRASTRUCTURE
OPERATIONS RELIEVING THE CIO
FROM DAY TO DAY I T. OPERATIONS
TO FOCUS ON HEALTH INFORMATICS
STRATEGIC PLANNING. AND OTHER
INITIATIVES TO MAXIMIZE. MS
ASIDE FOR EFFECTIVENESS AS A
BUSINESS ENABLING ORGANIZATION.
PROPOSAL NUMBER THREE IS THE
MULTI COUNTY LOCAL EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AGENCY FUNDING
INCREASE MS OUR REQUEST TWO
MILLION TEN THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND ONGOING THE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S MULTI COUNTY LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCIES THIS FUNDING WILL
AUGMENT EXISTING RESOURCES FOR
MULTI COUNTY LENSES TO CONTINUE
STATUTORILY MANDATED
RESPONSIBILITIES AND ADDRESS
SERVICE DELIVERY GAPS DRIVEN BY
COST INCREASES FROM INCREASED
TOURISM POPULATION GROWTH AND
INCREASED MANDATES OVERTIME. MS
ARE IN ACCORDANCE WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY CONTROL SECTION WITH
SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN DOT ONE
AWAY SUPPORT SUPPLEMENTAL
GENERAL FUND. PASQUINI PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL GENERAL FUND TWO
POINT TWO MILLION SYSTEMS MULTI
CHANNEL GONZALEZ LOCATED IN
LARGE RURAL AREAS AND ALSO
SMALLER POPULATIONS AND LIMITED
FINANCIAL HEALTH CARE RESOURCES.
SUPPLEMENTAL STATE FUNDING IS TO
BE USED TO PROVIDE ONLY
ESSENTIAL MINIMUM SERVICES
NECESSARY TO OPERATE THE LOCAL
EMS SYSTEMS AS DEFINED BY HEALTH
AND SAFETY. CODE SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN DOT ONE AWAY. ALL
THE COUNTY WINS NOT RISK
INCREASING JOE FUND SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TWO
THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR- IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE A SUPPLEMENTAL STATE
FUNDING NEEDS MULTI COUNTY WHIMS
OF MUST CONTAIN AT LEAST THREE
COUNTIES AND ALSO PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS OF AT LEAST ONE
DOLLAR. FOR EACH DOLLAR STATE
FUNDS RECEIVED MULTI COUNTY
LENSES WITH A POPULATION OF
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS
RECEIVE A FULL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING. WHICH THEY ARE ELIGIBLE
IF THEY PROVIDE AMOUNTS OF AT
LEAST FORTY ONE CENTS PER
CAPITA. JUNE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ALL ELIGIBLE TO CARRY
MEMBERS RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
GENERAL FUND. CURRENTLY THERE
ARE THIRTY THREE LENSES THAT
PROVIDE YOU MY SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE MERRICK
TWENTY SIX SINGLE COUNTY LENSES
AND SEVEN MULTI COUNTY. THE
SEVEN MOVIE COUNTY WINDOWS
CONTAINS THIRTY TWO OF THE
STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND PROVIDING MLS SERVICES TO
RESIDENT POPULATION
APPROXIMATELY SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION. FOR OVER TWO DECADES
COUNTY WHIMS OPERATIONAL COSTS
INCLUDING THOSE RELATED HE STATE
OBJECTIVES HAVE INCREASED. STATE
FUNDING FOR ESSENTIAL SERVICES
THAT CAN BE A- WHIMS AS PROVIDE
WAS REDUCE. I WITH NO OFFSETTING
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION MOBILE
COUNTY LENSES AND TO CONTINUALLY
INCREASE LOCAL PROVIDER FEES AND
CERTIFICATION THE- HE'S
CONTINUED REDUCTION WILL
UNDERMINE THE ONES ABILITY TO
PLAN IMPLEMENT AND EVALUATE
THEIR YOU KNOW SYSTEMS.
INCLUDING CRISIS SUPPORT IN
GENERAL DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE. THEREFORE TO MEET
INCREASED EMS RESPONSIBILITIES
TO SUSTAIN AND ENHANCE CORE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS MANY M. S.
SYSTEM AND MAINTAIN SESSION
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE MULTI
CAROLINE'S REQUIRED ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDS- IS THE WEEKEND.
THANK YOU FOR A FINANCE. HI THIS
ISSUE NOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
ANYTHING ON THIS. NO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OKAY HI I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS EITHER IT'S
SEEMS REASONABLE AND THINGS WE
HAVE TO DO SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO-
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
END WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
AND WELCOME- DIRECTOR MARY
WATANABE WELCOME DIRECTOR. AND
I'M ACTUALLY GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO DAM SOUTHERNER CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WILL BE PROVIDED THE
UPPER RIVER TO PCPS. GOOD
AFTERNOON- SHARE AND SENATOR PAN
MANY OF STANDS OUT OF THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE NOW PROVIDE THE OVERVIEW OF
BOYS OUR STATE MINISTER TO
SUPPORT SERVICES B. C. P. AS
WELL AS OUR AB. TWO NINETY BCP.
SO PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES TO BOTH
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS. IS CRITICAL TO
SUPPORTING THE BBC'S MISSION TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS HEALTH CARE
RIGHTS. ENSURE A STABLE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
TO ENSURE THE BBC'S PROGRAM
AREAS HAVE THE RESOURCES
SERVICES AND TOOLS REQUIRED. TO
FULFILL THEIR DUTIES ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS. DVC SUBMITTED THREE
WORKER BCPS AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE FISCAL YEAR COVERS BUDGET.
ALL PENDING LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL
THESE BCPS WILL GREATLY WOULD
SEE. FORTY FOUR NEW POSITIONS
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THESE THREE
WORKER BCPS DID NOT INCLUDE THE
ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE.
POSITIONS NEEDED TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THE ANTICIPATED GROWTH
POSITIONS. HISTORICALLY THE
WHICH HE RECEIVES ONE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT POSITIONS
IN OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES. AND ONE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT POSITION. THE OFFICE OF
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION FOR EVERY
TO EXCUSE ME EVERY. TEN NEW
PROGRAM POSITIONS. THIS PROPOSAL
EVERY NEEDED SUPPORTAND ADDRESS
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD RESULTING
FROM THE NEW WORKLOAD BCP
POSITIONS THE PRIVATE PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANCE TO THE
TEAM WE SEE PROGRAM STAFF. DVC
IS REQUESTING EIGHT POSITIONS
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN ISSUES WE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
ONGOING FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND. TO ADDRESS THIS INCREASED
WORKLOAD. I CAN PAUSE THEIR FREE
QUESTIONS OR IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO
CONTINUE. WITH THE NEXT PROPOSAL
I THINK JUST CONTINUE WITH THE
NEXT PROPOSAL. AGAIN AB TWO
NINETY REQUIRES A DVC TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS WHICH
PROVIDERS AND HEALTH PLANS CAN
SEEK RATES ABOVE THE MEDICARE
RATES. RECEIVE PLAN DATA
REGARDING COST SAVINGS AND
RECOUP IS IN REVIEW HEALTH PLAN
DOCUMENTS TO VERIFY VERIFY PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE DAILY SEE SOME OF THE BUT
SUBMITTED A BUDGET CHIEF POSTAL.
AND RECEIVED APPROVAL FOR TWO
YEAR LIMITED EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT
REQUIREMENTS MAYBE TO NOT. THE
RESOURCES BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WERE
DENIED BECAUSE IT WAS UNCERTAIN
IF THE DEMONS HE'S ASKED ME TO
WORK WITH THE MATERIALIZE DUE TO
PENDING LITIGATION. THE
POTENTIAL DECREASE IN THIRD
PARTY PAYMENT ACTIVE. THIS
REQUESTED PROVIDE THE LIMITED TO
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ABLE TO
DO WE SEE TO ADDRESS WORKERS.
BUT IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THIS YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR RESULTING FROM
EIGHTY TO NINETY IMPLEMENTATION
. THE TEAM IS HE IS REQUESTING A
TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. THE
AMOUNT OF SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO THOUSAND OF THE SPHERE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. HIS
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
JUST HERE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR THE MAN IS CARE FUND TO
ADDRESS WORKLOAD AND MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF EACH CLIENT. I
WILL NOTE THE GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING WORKLOAD
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT EIGHTY TO
NINETY BEYOND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. RESOURCES FOR
ONGOING OR NOT REQUESTED IN THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND FINALLY THE
D. WHICH YOU WILL NOT FEEL THE
REQUESTED POSITIONS UNTIL THE
PENDING LITIGATION HAS BEEN
RESOLVED THERE'S BEEN DETERMINED
TO BE WHICH YOU MUST FOR.
IMPLEMENTING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
AB TWO. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW OF OUR TO BUDGET CHANGE
PEOPLES MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE STRESS OF THE ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME MR
HERSHEY TO- ILIO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COREY ISSUED A WITH
THE ONLY A WEEK WE REVIEWED
THESE TWO PROPOSALS AND HAVE NO
CONCERNS REYES OKAY I DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS TO THE DOCTOR PAN.
NO NO CONCERNS APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION- JUST SERVE AFRICA
MY PREVIOUS COMMENT THAT NOW
EVERY TIME I START SEEING LARGE
YOU SEE PEOPLE'S I MAY BE
ASKING- ARE INCLUDING
ADMINISTRATIVE AND I. T. SUPPORT
FOR THESE PEOPLE SO THAT WE GET
A FEW BUT SOMETIMES LIKE YOU GET
THIRTY. THIS OPPOSITION. EIGHT
HOURS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND
- SOMETIMES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT POSITIONS IN THEIR-
CELL- SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT HOW. IS SYSTEMATICALLY LOOK
AT THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DR PAN AND NOT AND
THANK YOU- MISTER SADDAM FOR
THE- PRESENTATION WE DO
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY MOVING ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
THEY HAVE A ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS-
PHARMACY MODERNIZATION PHASE
THREE WE HAVE ANDREW HINKLE AND-
BRETT HAUSER PERHAPS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRETT HAUSER CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS OUR CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER ANDREW HE WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
AFTER THE OVERVIEW. CONDITION
NUMBER ONE RELATED TO PHARMACY
MODERNIZATION BASED THREE
APARTMENT ST HOSPITAL'S REQUEST
REAPPROPRIATION OF TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY JUDITH THIS WE ARE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. TO CONTINUE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PHARMACY MODERNIZATION PROJECT.
IN ADDITION TO THE RE
APPROPRIATION REQUEST YES H.
REQUEST THREE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS A TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
AND ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN TO COMPLETE THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE AT ALL
HOSPITALS. AND COVER INITIAL
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION COSTS
. THIS PROJECT INCLUDES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN INVENTORY
CONTROL SYSTEM UNIT DOSE RE
PACKAGING EQUIPMENT. AUTOMATED
DRUG DISPENSING SYSTEM EQUIPMENT
AND PHARMACY DATA INTEGRATION-
TO REMEDY AND CONSISTENT
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE ISSUES
REFRESHER QUICK MEANT. IMPROVE
LABOR INTENSIVE MEASURES TO
SAFEGUARD THE MEDICATIONS AND
IMPROVE OUR PHARMACY MANAGEMENT
AND MEDICATION ADMINISTRATION TO
OUR PATIENTS. THAT CONCLUDES A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
BERMAN FINANCE. THE HER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FOR THAT. MR SHIDA. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- KOREA SHE'D ALEJO
WEAK WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
ON THIS PROPOSAL. THIRTY THE
BRIEF QUESTION BECAUSE- THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY REAPPROPRIATION BY
NOTE THAT THE REAPPROPRIATION
REGIONALS TWENTY SEVEN WELL TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION AND NOW IT'S
THREE POINT TWO MILLION IS THAT
JUST TO RISING COSTS ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITIES OR
CAPABILITIES THAT ARE BEING PUT
IN THAT WASN'T IN THE ORIGINAL
REQUEST OF WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINALLY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION. IT IS TWO FOLD ONE OF
THE REAPPROPRIATION IS DUE TO A
DELAY DURING THE PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND APPROVAL
PROCESS BUT WE ARE ALSO
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BASED ON A TRUE GOT SOME ACTUAL
COSTS AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
PROCUREMENT PHASE WITH THE
VENDOR. OKAY INSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY- CAPABILITIES- IF IT
INCLUDED AS WELL FROM THE
ORIGINAL- PROPOSAL BACK ON WE
THOUGHT WAS TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IT SPACE
BASICALLY JUST TRYING UP ACTUAL
COSTS- THE GO OPEN THE
CAPABILITIES REMAIN REMAIN THE
SAME AS WE ANTICIPATE ORIGINALLY
SCULPTED JUST ADDITIONAL COST AT
THIS TIME. OKAY SO WELL. I AM
SUPPORTING ADDED BY NOTE THAT
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE-
IN COST- DIFFERENT SAID IN THAT
PERIOD TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OKAY LET'S THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION AND LET'S
MOVE ON TO. I THINK ARE FINALLY
SHOOT. I COULD BE WRONG BROWN
FREQUENTLY AT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION- THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER ONE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT PARTNERSHIP
GRANT PROGRAM AUTHORITY- MISTER
EWING. WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CENTER PAN AM AND- OTHER
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT BE
REMOTELY AS OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA ITEM THE COMMISSION IS A
MASTERING THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT GRANT PROGRAM
THROUGH WHICH WE PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FUNDS TO SUPPORT
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES HI WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED FIFTY FOUR
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
REMAINING FOR COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE BEARS AND
THEY HAVE TO PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM WHICH ARE LARGELY
RELATED TO STAFFING- BUT WE MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
ROLLING OUT. THAT THAT PROGRAM
YEAH I'M MOVING TOWARDS THE
VISION OF THE LEGISLATURE PUT IN
PLACE WHEN A DOCTOR THAT ACT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU
IS A REQUEST TO. AUTHORIZE FIVE
POSITIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS THAT WE
WANT TO TURN INTO PERMANENT
POSITIONS RECOGNIZING THAT THE
MHSAA IS AN ONGOING ACT AND THAT
WE HOPE TO BE AND THAT IS IN THE
BUSINESS OF SUPPORTING MENTAL
HEALTH I THE SCHOOLS IN THE
LONG TERM THERE'S NO FINING
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS I WE HAVE
LIMITED TERM DOLLARS AT THE
MOMENT TO SUPPORT THE LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS AND THEN WILL
TRANSITION FUNDING FOR THOSE
POSITIONS BUT NOT LIMITED TURNED
OUT AND TO THE ONGOING FINDINGS
THAT ALREADY IS AVAILABLE IN OUR
TO SUPPORT THE ACT. HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. ABOUT THIS
REQUEST YOU HAVE. THANK YOU THE
FINANCE. THEY'RE ALMOST OF
PAYMENT OF FINE OF THE FURTHER
TO OKAY THE BILL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- NOPE NO CONCERNS
RAISED ON THIS ONE. OKAY AND THE
POSITIONS ARE ARE THE ONES LAID
OUT THAT. YOUR AS LIKE BUT
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM ANALYST
ASSOCIATE OR THEY ARE THE ONES
LISTED ON PAGE TWENTY EIGHT OF
OUR. OKAY SO THAT IS THE FORM
OKAY OKAY. WELL WHAT WE'RE
SAYING THAT WE'RE GONNA IS
EXCITED THAT WE'RE GONNA START
DOING MORE OF THIS WORK AT AND
WIND THE TERM ENDS FOR THE
FUNDING YOU HAVE IS YOUR PLAN TO
EVALUATE IF THESE POSITIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE. THAT NEEDED. THE
GOAL IS TO FIND THESE POSITIONS.
I WITH THE ONGOING FINDS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION. IT
WILL MEAN WE WILL BE MOVING SOME
FUNDS FROM LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FINDING IN THE STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING- THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT YOU KNOW MUCH OF THE WORK
IS ACTUALLY ABOUT SUPPORTING THE
CAPACITY. OF OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
TAX TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN STANDING
OUT AND MOVING FORWARD WITH
CITIES. AB SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH STRATEGIES SO WE DON'T AT
THIS TIME INVASION COMING BACK
TO ASK FOR MORE FUNDING THAT'S
YOUR POINT. I HAVE OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS WE INTEND TO LEARN A
LOT ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AND WE
EXPECT TO BE. SHARING THAT
INFORMATION WITH YOU AND IT MAY
RESULT IN SOME ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO BE
SUCCESSFUL OR- OKAY THAT'S
GREAT- WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
WORK BEGINNING AND THAT WORK AT
CONTINUING AND MAKING A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN. IN OUR OUR
STUDENTS LIVES AFFECTED. OKAY WE
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION-
AND THAT THAT TAKES US TO THE
END OF OUR- AGENDA FOR THE DAY-
SO I GUESS WE'LL SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
BROOM HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT AND I DO.
SEE ONE PERSON APPROACHING
PLEASE YOUR NAME POSITION AND
MUCH LIKE STATUS TODAY THANK YOU
I THINK WE'RE NOW AT THE
AFTERNOON HOURS SO GOOD
AFTERNOON I CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. REALLY WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION ON ISSUE ONE THIS
MORNING I WANT TO OFFER. OUR
SUPPORT- REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INVEST A
HUNDRED MILLION- TO UPDATE
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES
FOLLOWING THAT THAT I HAVE STATE
REALIGNMENT OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO COUNTIES. AND
I THINK YOU'RE A DIRECTOR LA
SERO I THINK REALLY
COMPREHENSIVELY COVERED MANY OF
THE IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF THE
EXTENSIVE WORK THAT. I COUNTIES
ARE DOING AS IT RELATES TO-
BRINGING TOGETHER AT VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO DO THE EXTENSIVE
COUNTY PLANNING THAT WE KNOW
THAT IS. VERY IMPORTANT- TO
BRING INTO ALL OF THIS TO
FRUITION IN THE WAYS THAT WE ALL
COLLECTIVELY WANT TO SEE- I
WOULD NOTE THAT WE YOU KNOW AS
WAS STATED WE HAVE YOU CURRENTLY
IN OUR FACILITIES THAT I THINK-
COULD STRONGLY BENEFIT FROM THE
STATE SUPPORT- IN THIS REGARD TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE FACILITY NEEDS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN
THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
PLANS- ESPECIALLY RECOGNIZING
THAT THE- TREATMENT NEEDS OF
MANY OF THESE YOUTH IN THE
LONGER TERM STAYS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE- AS WELL- WE ENVISION
THIS FUNDING BEING ABLE TO BE
USED FOR THINGS LIKE CREATING-
INDOOR OUTDOOR RECREATION SPACE-
EDUCATIONAL SPACE. OF VOCATIONAL
AS WELL AND CERTAINLY
MODERNIZING AND CREATING KIND OF
MORE THERAPEUTIC A NORMATIVE-
ENVIRONMENTS- IN BOTH OUR UNITS
AND SLEEPING ROOMS AND SO- WE
REALLY SEE THIS AS AS
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE GREAT WORK
THAT IS ALREADY HAPPENING AS IT
RELATES TO PROVIDING SERVICES
AND TREATMENT FOR YOUTH LOCALLY-
FURTHER ENHANCING THAT BY AGAIN
MAKING SURE THE IN. THE
ENVIRONMENT- ARE ARE KIND OF
COMPLEMENTARY TO THAT SO- AS OF
QUESTIONS CONTINUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPLE SUPPORT ON THIS- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING ANYMORE
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN TO BE
HELPFUL IN THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I AND I AND I'M SURE AND I
AND I- I HOPE THAT WERE ALSO
INCLUDING USE VOICES WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE A
WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT AND
LOOKING AROUND ALL ISSUES. OF
DIVERSITY AND WELCOMING. A AND I
BY RICH OUT TO MR OVERSEE HERE
SAYING I WANT TO GO SEE THAT
THIS. PROGRAMS AND- IN MY THREE
COUNTIES- BECAUSE I CERTAINLY
HEARD FROM SOME OF THEM- OKAY-
ASSISTED OBSERVING NOBODY ELSE
IN THIS ROOM ALL TURN TO THE
PHONE LINE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY PEOPLE THERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT. YOUR NAME.
AGENCY AND- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SAY TO US TODAY. MODERATOR YOU
THERE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE PROVIDE
A LINE NUMBER FOR THE FIRST
QUESTION- I'M UNDER.
WE GOT OUR FIRST LINE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET AFTERNOON
THANK YOU SHARING COMMITTEE RYAN
MORGAN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION AND
COUNTY. IN REGARDS TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THE OPPOSITE OF THE
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
I THINK HE'S ACTIVE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE PROPOSED
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GIVING OUT. PRUDENT IN
APPRECIATED MINISTRATION
REPORTER COUNTY THAT YOU'RE NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE NEW
POPULATION REALIGN YOU. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK DIRECTOR ERIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HOWARD FOR
THEIR TIRELESS WORKING
ENGAGEMENT WITH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY. BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT
I'M VERY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMMING AND STAFFING
CHALLENGES. WELL WE RECOGNIZE
THE DETAILS OF THE GRANT PROCESS
THE PROPOSAL ARE NOT FINALIZED
THANK GOD EARLIER IN THE
PRESENTATION. IN BY OUR
COLLEAGUE- FROM DETOX WE LIKE TO
REINFORCE THE URGENCY OF FINDING
DISTRIBUTION. AT THE END YOU
THERE ARE. HOUSE ADDITIONALLY WE
LIKE NO THAT CALM REDESIGN IN
MODERN LOCAL FACILITY COULD IF
HE A MILLION THEY WILL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED. ENSURE
THAT OF YOU AND THAT NOW COUNTY
LARGEST. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE HEARING TODAY REALLY THANK
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR WORK AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
IN THE L. A. O. AND OF COURSE
THE STAFF HERE IN THIS ROOM IN
PREPARATION AND IN EXECUTION AND
WITH THAT- THIS MEETING OF
BUDGET SUB THREE IS ADJOURNED.